bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement aujourd'hui
j'accueille stéphane thebaut of docteur
en psychologie évolutive est également
président du café des sciences c'est
différent association qui regroupe
beaucoup de vulgarisateur scientifique
du web
beau joueur stéphane salue les est-ce
que tu peux nous présenter un petit peu
ton parcours d'un professionnel ouais
tout à fait alors j'ai commencé par un
bac scientifique
après le bac j'ai décidé d'aller en
prépa biologie dans ce qu'on appelle la
prépa bcpst et j'ai choisi ça en fait
parce que c'était la voix qui me
semblait fermé le moins de portes
donc j'ai choisi prépa par rapport à fac
parce que soi disant c'est plus facile
de passer de la prépare la fac de la fac
la prépa et j'ai choisi prépa bio parce
qu'en fait c'est a priori c'est la prépa
qui ferme le moins de discipline c'est à
dire ça s'appelle bcpst ça veut dire
biologie chimie physique sciences de la
terre et je comprends pas pourquoi il
n'ya pas le m2 mathématiques parce qu'on
fait aussi pas mal de mathématiques dans
cette voie en fait je crois même que
c'est super bien c'est je crois que
c'est un tiers de maths un tiers de
physique-chimie et un tiers de bureau en
gros donc on appelait ça près fabio mais
c'est vraiment bien équilibrée alors
qu'il me semble que en maths par exemple
vous avez plus de biologie si en prépa
maths j'ai pas fait de biologie depuis
et puis le lycée crise et du coup ça ça
me plaisait pas et en plus de ça on fait
encore delà de la philo on fait de la
géographie et puis on fait des langues
vivantes enfin c'était une prépa qui
m'avait l'air vraiment sympa parce que
la bardot n'est pas de discipline
[Musique]
donc voila apres pas bio ensuite après à
la fin de ma prépa g
je suis allé à l'école normale
supérieure de paris mais ça c'était un
peu un hasard en fait moi je suis
débarqué en prépa je ne savais pas que
ça existait le ce qu'on appelle le n s
l'école normale supérieure pendant toute
l'après pas en fait je me suis dit c'est
beaucoup trop dur pour toi parce qu'en
fait c'est ce qu'on sait ce qu'on nous
répète très souvent en quoi c'est un des
concours les plus durs moi je voulais
faire ingénieur agronome j'étais très
content avec ça donc j'ai préparé et et
j'ai passé toute ma prépa à préparer le
concours d'ingénieur agronome et en fait
ce qui s'est passé c'est que en deuxième
année
j'en avais tellement marre de la prépa
je trouvais ça vraiment tellement trop
dur qu'en fait je n'aimais pas les
méthodes d'apprentissage que je me suis
dit allez je vais passer tous les
concours possibles et imaginables en 2e
année histoire d'être sûr de pas
redoubler quoi et même les concours de
géologie 1 c'est pour te dire j'ai passé
les géologistes pour dire à quel point
j'étais désespéré cet ebook de la
géologie conséquence michael
non mais on y reviendra en fait c'est
super la géologie mais bref j'ai même
failli intégrer une école de géologie en
fait pour la petite histoire j'ai raté
j'ai raté le concours de la nes de
géologie à quelques places
ainsi si je l'avais eue il est probable
que j'aurais fait des études de géologie
et vite et bien et alors est ce qui
s'est passé en fait c'est que j'ai donc
j'ai rater les tous les concours de ems
par contre on peut aussi intégrer les
ems sur dossier on peut envoyer un
dossier ils ont deux voies de
recrutement sur concours sur dossier et
moi j'ai envoyé mon dossier et à ma
grande surprise ils m'ont acceptée quoi
j'étais ça devait être le mois de
juillet août j'étais prêt à partir en
école d'ingé agronome et puis j'ai reçu
un email qui me disait que j'étais
accepté à l'école normale supérieure de
paris et ce qui m'a fait choisir ça en
fait
alors il faut savoir qu'on est bon on
n'est pas payé le nsc une école un peu
particulière dans le sens où ce qui
intègre sur concours ils sont payés ceux
qui intègrent sur dossier ils ont
exactement les mêmes cours que les
autres mais ils sont pas payés et ce qui
m'a fait choisir d y aller quand même
c'est une fois de plus le fait que
c'était ultra interdisciplinaire donc en
particulier le fait alors c'est un peu
une spécificité de l'école de ness de
paris c'est un peu différent
le ms de cachan et de lyon mais à
lunesse de paris ils ont toutes les
disciplines regroupées sur un même
campus c'est à dire qu'il ya un
département de chimie un département de
physique biologie informatique maths etc
mais il ya aussi au même endroit
département de lettres classiques
département de lettres modernes
département de sciences humaines
archéologie et puis c'est non seulement
possible d'aller prendre des cours dans
ces départements mais en plus c'est
recommandé
c'est à dire que si tu veux tu peux très
bien obtenir un diplôme de mns de
physique par exemple avec une mineure
philosophie de l'esprit où tu peux
passer un diplôme de mad tu vois tu peux
avoir ton diplôme de maths avec une
mineure archéologie grecs ont le truc
comme ça et ça c'est vraiment un truc
que je sais pas si c'est unique en
france mais en tout cas il y en a il y
en a pas beaucoup et c'est ça qui m'a
convaincu d'aller là-bas de débarquer la
main je te fais un peu la version longue
de mai de mes choix de carrière ainsi tu
veux que j'accélère tête et du cou tu
avais fait quoi toi comme majeurs et
mineurs vous avez une mineure j'ai fait
non j'ai pas fait le mineur parce que en
fait j'étais je me suis trop dispersée
pour faire une mineure majeur c'était
biologie et pour faire une mineure il
faut accumuler un certain nombre de 2
cts les unités d'enseignement dans une
certaine discipline et donc moi j'ai pas
fait ça je suis allé prendre des cours à
droite à gauche un peu partout et je
n'avais pas assez de cts dans une même
discipline pour avoir une mineure elle
est née cette idée du taf et les études
en biologie du coup ouais c'est ça alors
j'ai fait licence de biologie j'entre en
licence de biologie mais déjà en licence
je me rends compte que la biologie qu'on
nous enseigne c'est plus trop là
biologique que j'aime c'est à dire c'est
très moléculaire très cellulaire
training génétique en fait c'est le les
échelles petit col est plus petite
échelle qu'on étudie en biologie et moi
ce qui m'intéressait déjà en licence
étaient les échelles plus macroscopique
donc comprendre notamment l'humain le
cerveau humain la pensée et c est donc
ce qui fait que l on n est cependant ma
licence j'ai fait ma licence de biologie
mais j'attendais qu'une chose quand
j'allais en cours c'était de pouvoir
aller suivre le soir les cours
d'introduction aux sciences cognitives
qui était donné par le département de
sciences cognitives et c'est là où on
parlait vraiment de choses qui me veut
qui me fascine et donc toutes les
grandes fonctions mentales la mémoire la
conscience la perception et s'est passé
dans ces cours là que j'ai découvert par
exemple l'élimination wismes qui
s'appelle aujourd'hui l'illusionnisme
d'après monsieur file la vidéo sur les
zombies qui vient de faire c'est dans
ces cours là aussi l'introduction
science cognitive que j'ai découvert la
machine de turing
on le présente la machine de turing
comme une espèce de métaphore du cerveau
humain de ce que fait cerveau humain du
traitement de l'information
si j'ai bien compris des vidéos à toi
c'est même d'ailleurs un peu plus qu'une
métaphore que c'est vraiment enfin voila
c'est des trucs des trucs que j'ai
trouvé fascinant et donc j'ai décidé de
pas continuer en biologie j'ai décidé de
switcher pour faire un master 2 sciences
cognitives spécifiquement des corps mais
si tu as fait tout au master ces
territoires et jeunesse ouais toujours
alone est-ce juste à côté
j'étais pas très loin et il reste ce qui
se passe c'est que donc je m'épanouis
vraiment dans ce dans cette discipline
mais on me parle plus du tout de
biologie et plus du tout de biologie de
l'évolution
c'est à dire qu'en fait on est en train
d'étudier
un organe qui est un organe comme un
autre coin de la matière vivante le
cerveau et on nous parle plus du tout de
la discipline qui est censé expliquer
comment la matière vivante et structurée
et ben ça ça va ça m'embêtait un peu du
coup je me suis demandé est-ce qu'il
existerait pas des disciplines qu'ils
fassent ça qui étudie le cerveau mais
dans une perspective évolutionnaire
c'est là que j'ai découvert cette
discipline qui s'appelle psychologie
évolutionnaire ou psychologie
évolutionniste et j'ai décidé de me
lancer là dedans je suis parti ce que
j'ai fait je suis j'ai pris une année de
césure d'un an et je suis parti faire un
stage en californie chez de type qui sa
fin un mec est une femme qui s'appelle
t'oublier cosmi days qui seront
considérés un peu comme les les
créateurs de la psychologie
évolutionnaire plutôt ceux qui l'ont
qu'ils ont remis au goût du jour au
début des années 90 où j'ai pris cette
année de césure à la fois pour essayer
de décider si j'avais envie de faire une
thèse et si j'avais envie de faire une
thèse en particulier en psychologie
évolutionnaire est bien là la réponse à
ces deux questions a été oui quoi là
c'était deux fois oui ok du coup tu as
fait ta thèse été fait l'a été en france
ouais je suis rentré en france alors
j'ai eu la chance de trouver un labo en
france parce que c'est une discipline
qui est vraiment pas très très développé
en france je crois qu'il doit y avoir
il ya un labo il ya des gens qui font un
peu de la recherche là dessus à
montpellier je crois qu'on a un petit
peu à lyon et puis un petit peu à paris
aussi c'est plus des équipes de
recherche à l'intérieur de laboratoire
que vraiment des laboratoires à part
entière et donc à paris je suis tombé
sur une équipe qui faisait ça et en plus
qui étudié un sujet que je trouve
passionnant qui est le sujet de
l'évolution de la morale et donc voilà
j'ai des bingos je me lance là dedans et
clint tadic en france c'était mon défunt
s'était peu développé ce que c'est moins
développé qu'ailleurs
ouais c'est certain c'est une discipline
qui est très anglo-saxonne la
psychologie évolutionnaire et en france
alors c'est probablement dû à des
raisons historiques mais on a très peu
de l'équipe qui travaille là dessus et
expliquerait les cinq ans va une des
interprétations de beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent dans le milieu c'est qu'il
ya vraiment une très forte emprise des
sciences humaines et sociales en france
sur l'explication des comportements
humains et que du coup dès que tu
commences à dire que les sciences
humaines et sociales ne peuvent pas tout
expliquer que la culture est
effectivement un rôle mais que la
biologie à son rôle
tu te fais tout de suite attaqué très
fort en tout cas c'est pas des idées qui
qui arrive facilement à se développer
quoi tout arrive pas facilement à
développer ses idées c'est spécifique à
la france vous et c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre que c'est qu'on a qu'on a
vraiment une tradition de grands
penseurs en sociologie en sciences
humaines et sociales qui ont très
longtemps
alors je ne sais pas si dénigrer
vraiment les explications biologiques
mais en tout cas il insistait énormément
sur les explications culturelles et
voilà après la psychologie
évolutionnaire et quand même
rejetez pas pour des bonnes raisons
selon moi dans les pays anglo saxons des
problèmes des problèmes idéologiques qui
se pose avec la psychologie
évolutionnaire pas qu'en france mais de
de ce que j'ai compris et puis c'est un
peu mon expérience aussi c'est quelque
chose qui est très fort en france ouai
ok ils ont pas eu l'occasion d'être
confronté avec des sceptiques et de
biologie de la psychologie
évolutionnaire en france sur internet
web pendant mes études pas tellement
parce que parce que même les gens qui
font pas de la psychologie
évolutionnaire pur et dur ils ont quand
même une approche révolutionnaire une
pensée révolutionnaire s'est passé par
rare que tu vois un neuroscientifique
quelqu'un qui fait de neurosciences de
l'imagerie de l'irm tout ça qui fait une
présentation est dans sa première slide
dans sa dernière spies il va te vas te
dire il va te présenter des explications
évolutionnaire de ceux qui l'étudient
quoi c'est vraiment une pensée dans les
milieux scientifiques dans lesquels j'ai
évolué au moins qui est très présente
mais par contre dès que tu sors de ces
milieux là et dès que tu vas dans les
milieux plus sciences sociales sciences
humaines que moi j'ai rencontré sur
internet personnellement pourrais tu te
retrouves avec des gens qui sont
vraiment vraiment vraiment hooligans
pour reprendre ton terme les gens qui
veulent qu'ils veulent pas accepter par
idéologie selon moi qu'ils puissent
avoir des bases biologiques à certains
comportements humains hockey est donc
d'abord parler de ta tête on reviendra
sur les critiques des anglophones peut
pas leur tête et est donc le titre de
thé dresser l'évolution morale
ouais l'évolution du sens de l'équité
plus précisément les explications
évolutionnaire du sens de l'équité mais
voilà c'est très lié à la morale
écossais colis des global
alors l'idée globale c'est de comprendre
d'où vient la morale et de comprendre
donc c'est d'essayer de faire ce qu'on
apprend ce qu'on appelle une approche
naturaliste de la morale c'est d'essayer
de comprendre d'où vient la
morales avec les seules lois dont on
dispose qui sont les lois de la physique
et la biologie
dans ce cadre là l'idée c'est d'essayer
de comprendre à quoi un peu bien plus
servir un sens moral au cours de
l'évolution
j'ai en fait j'ai essayé de comprendre
la raison pour laquelle un sens moral
serait apparu donc d'essayer de trouver
quels sont les avantages qu aurait pu
apporter un sens moral en termes de
survie et de reproduction au cours de
l'évolution
et comment tu fais ça alors comment on
fait ça on fait moi ce que j'ai fait
beaucoup c'est des modèles d'un modèle
vieux modèles informatiques modèle
mathématique j'ai fait donc j'ai fait
une vidéo sur ta chaîne quand tu disais
tu as ta série sur la démocratie les
gens qui sont intéressés je pense qu'ils
pourront aller voir les détails de sa ça
s'appelait comment ça s'appelait le
paradoxe des anoraks et là j'explique
les modèles en détails donc l'idée donc
moi j'avance en général la façon dont on
procède en psychologie évolutionnaire je
peux peut-être dire un mot là-dessus en
premier la psychologie évolutionnaire
elle est souvent critiquée parce que on
dit qu'elle raconte ce qu'on appelle en
anglais des just so stories
c'est à dire des des histoires pour les
enfants ou des histoires des histoires à
dormir debout ce genre de truc en ski et
ski et une critique qui est vraiment un
type qui est généralement avancés par
les gens qui connaissent pas du tout le
champ qu'en fait ce qui se passe en
psychologie évolutionnaire c'est qu'on a
on a deux façons de travailler il ya une
façon qu'on appelle top down est une
façon qu'on appelle bottom up donc une
façon du haut vers le bas
une façon du bas vers le haut la façon
du haut vers le bas elle par des
explications ou des hypothèses
révolutionnaire pour ensuite aller
tester les mécanismes du cerveau donc tu
peux dire par exemple
moi j'ai l'hypothèse que la morale elle
a évolué parce que elle permettait au
groupe qui qui contenait le plus
d'individus moreau de mieux survivre
face aux groupes qui contenait le moins
d'individus moreau ils ont donc les
groupes c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'hypothèse de sélection de groupes
les groupes qui comportait le moins
d'individus moreau ou altruiste ils ont
moins bien survécu
que ce soit par compétition directe
guerre etc
ou compétition indirects l'exploitation
des ressources face aux individus face
aux groupes qui contenaient moins
d'individus moreau donc ça c'est
l'hypothèse et évolutionnaire et c'est
vrai que si tu dis juste ça bah c'est
vraiment bizarre qu'enfin on attend les
preuves pour aller démontré cette
hypothèse
évidemment ce que font les chercheurs en
psychologie évolutionnaire ils font pas
des papiers où ils font ça ils disent de
moi mon hypothèse sur la morale c'est ça
et puis hop c'est fini et puis ils ont
publié un papier ce qui se passe c'est
qu'ensuite qu'il va essayer de chercher
quelques prédictions cette hypothèse
fait sur le fonctionnement du cerveau
humain ou sur le fonctionnement d'un
moral aujourd'hui donc par exemple si tu
penses que la morale a évolué par
sélection de groupes
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui la morale
des gens devraient être utilitariste
donc ça veut dire que les gens ils
devraient à trouver moral de votre vie
acceptable de se sacrifier pour son
groupe par exemple un homme ça doit
pouvoir aller faire des expériences pour
tester si la morale des gens et
utilitariste ne serait pas tout à fait
dit terry ça ça puisse se défendre pour
la survie du groupe
la façon dont le bonheur des individus
du groupe ouais ouais ouais tu as raison
tu as raison tu peux faire cette
distinction là bas après tu peux
toujours dire que le la survie du groupe
c'est ça qui va apporter du bonheur aux
groupes enfin c'est vrai que ça dépend
un petit peu de ta définition de
l'utilitarisme mais en tout cas l'idée
générale c'est que tu peux faire des
prédictions quoi si tu as une hypothèse
révolutionnaire tu peux dire s'il s'est
passé cela dans le passé alors on doit
retrouver sa dans le présent aujourd'hui
et c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve un
peu dans toutes les disciplines qui
étudie le passé d'ailleurs c'est un
sujet que je voulais discuter avec toi
en particulier toutes ces disciplines
qui étudie le passé que ce soit
l'archéologie la cosmologie elles font
un petit peu ceinture à elle 10 6 est
passé ça dans le passé alors on doit
retrouver sa dans le présent et tu va
tester ça dans le présent et si tu
trouves tu as prédictions et m'as tu
donnes un peu plus de crédit à ton
hypothèse et si tu trouves pas une
prédiction facile du trouve que si la
prédiction n'est pas confirmée tu donnes
un petit peu moins de crédits attendit
potel hockey et mais du coup ça
fonctionne souvent comme ça c'est bien
on essaie de faire des prédictions sur
ce
on espère découvrir sur le concept on va
dire sur tu penses à quoi typiquement
parce que j'imagine qu'une des critiques
qu'on fait d'eux la psychologie
évolutionnaire c'est que on sait déjà
qu'elle est comportement de désunion
aujourd'hui il est tel qu'il est et du
coup c'est pas vraiment une prédiction
mais j'imagine que ce genre de critiques
montant ouais tout à fait mais en fait
tu justement alors ses prédictions que
tu sais déjà ce et des prédictions qui
vont avoir moins de poids mais en fait
tu peux faire des prédictions que tu ne
sais pas déjà c'est à dire tu peux faire
des prédictions qui vont apprendre des
choses sur le cerveau humain
c'est vraiment un sac que la psychologie
évolutionnaire est génial c'est qu'elle
te elle te permet de faire des
prédictions qui t'apprennent des
nouvelles choses alors pour donner un
exemple prenons le cas des biais de
raisonnement par exemple tu observes les
billets de raisonnement que tu vois chez
l'humain donc c'est au cas où les gens
sont pas soit pas au courant c'est le
fait que le raisonnement des humains et
est sujet à tout un tas de biais
notamment des biais de raisonnement
motivé c'est à dire que quand on
raisonne on va sélectionner uniquement
les arguments qui viennent conforter les
croyances que l'on avait à priori
et donc quand tu quand tu vois ça donc
c'est vraiment un truc qui est massif en
psychologie en avoir on a repéré des
dizaines de biais de raisonnements comme
ça et alors là il ya un petit peu de
stratégie moi je dirais dans un sentier
la stratégie des économistes alors je
vais faire un petit peu d'économistes
bashing après le géologue qui font ça
ils s'aperçoivent que le raisonnement
humain est biaisé une pipe offs et où il
s'arrête là ils disent le raisonnement
est bien humain est biaisé point final
donnez moi mon prix nobel et puis on
sera tous très contents c'est ici qu'est
né ce qui s'est dit et les géologues
géologue qui disait encore les tripes
pardon mais les économistes et alors que
là à ce moment là un biologiste de
l'évolution ou un psychologue
révolutionnaire il se dirait comment ça
se fait que le raisonnement humain il
est biaisé pour pourquoi on a tous ses
billets de raisonnement pourquoi le
raisonnement humain il n'a pas l'air de
chercher à trouver la vérité ou prendre
des bonnes décisions il a vraiment
un d'être là juste pour justifier nos
opinions qu'on avait a priori et à
partir de ce que tu observes alors là ce
que je suis en train de décrire c'est
justement la proche bottom up dont je
peux parler là tout à l'heure je te
décris l'approchent top d'armes du du
haut vers le bas c'est à dire des
théories révolutionnaires au cerveau
humain là je lâche celle approche
contraire donc tu pars de ce que tu
observes et tu vas en déduire une
théorie révolutionnaire donc là tu pars
du fait que tu observes plein de vienne
raisonnement et tu te dis bon bien le
raisonnement humain au fait ça sert pas
à produire de la vérité ça sert à
convaincre les autres dans un débat par
exemple à convaincre les autres que tu
as raison c'est pour c'est ce qu'on
appelle la théorie argumentative du
raisonnement donc ça dit que le
raisonnement humain ça sert à produire
des arguments non seulement pour essayer
de convaincre les autres que tu as
raison dans un débat mais aussi pour
évaluer les arguments des autres
histoire que les autres ils te raconte
pas n'importe quoi donc là on est on est
partie des données on génère une
hypothèse évolutionnaire et là ce qui
est important maintenant c'est d'essayer
de revenir aux données pour faire de
nouvelles prédictions donc par exemple
tu peux faire la prédiction tu peux te
dire si jamais c'est vraiment ça la
fonction du règlement humain si le
raisonnement humain a évolué parce qu'il
nous permettait de mieux de plus
facilement convaincre les autres alors
on s'attendrait par exemple à ce que on
soit beaucoup plus fort pour argumenter
où on produisent beaucoup plus
d'arguments dans des situations sociales
quand on raisonne dans des situations
sociales avec d'autres gens que quand on
raisonne tout seul et ça par exemple
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne savait pas
vraiment enfin qu'on avait pas vraiment
auxquelles on n'avait pas vraiment pensé
à priori et c'est effectivement car les
gens sont beaucoup plus faciles pour
produire des arguments et pour raisonner
quand ils sont dans un contexte social
quand ils sont avec d'autres gens que
quand ils sont tous seuls chez eux
c'est intéressant sinon je l'aurais
parié intuitivement mais ces situations
de du coup il ya des expériences qui ont
vérifié s'agit - ouais ouais tout à fait
tout à fait les gens sont les gens sont
meilleurs sont des biens meilleurs
producteurs d'arguments bien meilleure
il résonne beaucoup plus ils raisonnent
pas mieux ils sont toujours sujets à
tous leurs biens le raisonnement mais
résonne plus dans des situations
sociales et ça c'est qu'en fait je te
dis ça je te dis ça comme si c'était
une méthode de la psychologie
évolutionnaire mais c'est c'est pas que
la psychologie
les biologistes de l'évolution ils font
exactement la même chose quand il
propose des explications pour
l'existence d'un organe du corps humain
par exemple tu peux dire la pigmentation
de la peau par exemple à quoi ça a servi
au cours d'évolution quelle est la
raison pour laquelle la pigmentation de
la peau a évolué qui pourraient faire
différentes hypothèses
une hypothèse ça va être que ça sert à
réguler la quantité d'ultra violets qui
passe à travers la peau mais tu pourrais
très bien lire une autre hypothèse c'est
que ça permet de se camoufler pour
échapper aux prédateurs
voilà c'est à deux hypothèses comment tu
fais pour les départager et ben à
nouveau tu vas essayer de faire des
prédictions et voir quelles prédictions
sont vérifiées donc par exemple si le la
pigmentation de la peau a évolué parce
que ça permettait de réguler
la quantité d'uv qui va traverser la
peau tu pourrais te dire que tu vas
trouver des pigmentations decaux qui
sont différentes chez des personnes qui
ont différents besoins en vitamine d
parce qu'on sait par exemple que le donc
on sait que les rayons ultraviolets sont
nécessaires pour produire la vitamine d
donc l'idée c'est que les personnes qui
ont plus de besoins en vitamine d ils
vont avoir une peau un petit peu plus
clair or il se trouve que les femmes par
exemple ont des besoins plus importants
en vitamine d parce que notamment à
cause de l'allaitement et de la
grossesse etc et donc il va faire la
prédiction que tu vas retrouver que les
femmes en général en moyenne et tout
autour du monde
elles vont avoir la peau légèrement plus
clair que les hommes qui est un truc
voilà c'est vraiment une prédiction que
tu as moins de buts que tu fasses est
pas intuitive toi c'est pas un truc gré
que tu observes très facilement et donc
c'est effectivement le cas quand tu va
regarder la pigmentation de la peau des
femmes et des hommes tous partout autour
du monde
tu te rends compte que les femmes ont en
général la peau légèrement plus clair ce
qui vient appuyer ton hypothèse alors ça
veut pas dire que ton hypothèse elle est
vrai à 100% mais ça donne un petit peu
plus de crédit à ton hypothèse
donc c'est juste pour dire que ce
raisonnement dont je te parle je fais
j'ai une hypothèse
je vais voir quels prédictions cette
hypothèse fait ensuite je vais tester
ses prédictions c'est pas que de la
psychologie évolutionnaire c'est de la
biologie de l'evolution jeu en général
toutes les sciences observationnelles je
pense que si on pense à des trucs qui
sont un peu plus un peu plus clairement
identifiées comme les sciences très dur
on va dire je mets des guillemets un peu
par ce mot pardon si je pense à la
cosmologie qui étudient finalement le
passé de l'univers
c'est finalement quelque chose de
semblable qui est fait regarde les
étoiles
on essaie de regarder le fond diffus
cosmologique bond cde
de l'affairé théorie pardon plata du big
bang et théorie de l'inflation
et puis on utilisera ensuite pour faire
d'autres prédictions sur ce qu'on
s'attend observée dans ce même si elle
est parfois il ya des trucs assez
spectaculaires où on a fait une
prédiction qui était assez étrange pour
difficile à faire autrement on va dire
ouais et si mission l'a confirmé
ça fait une grosse confort
potentiellement une grosse confirmation
de cette théorie du passé et mais du
coup ça ça contraste peut-être même un
petit peu ce que ça se décide quelque
chose d'assez observationnelles et on
peut pas faire vraiment d'expérience
contrôlée randomisée en double aveugle
je veux pas faire de l'expérience iii
randomisée est ce que tu sens une
tension entre ça et pas des descriptions
un peu naïve on va dire de la méthode
scientifique est ce que font un
tassement des critiques par exemple de
gens qui disent ouais mais on peut pas
faire d'expérience par exemple en
laboratoire bah oui oui ce sont des
critiques qui existent alors il ya des
gens qui disent ça ok vous avez confirmé
votre prédiction par exemple donc votre
hypothèse à un peu plus de crédit mais
on n'en sera jamais sûr à 100% c'est un
truc qui s'est passé dans le passé on ne
sera jamais sûr à 100% alors toi
évidemment je sais que ça te dérange pas
de conçoit pas sûr à 100% des choses
mais c'est un argument qui revient assez
souvent et c'est un argument
moi j'ai l'impression qu'on a par
exemple parlé de la cosmologie je trouve
qu'on le dit pas ça aux cosmologues
quand tu vois quand ils confirment leurs
prédictions on va pas les faire chier en
disant oui mais vous en ai pas sûr à
100% parce que vous étiez pas là au
moment de la formation du big bang
vous pouvez pas recréer un big bang en
laboratoire et je trouve qu'il est une
espèce d'injustice comme ça entre les
disciplines et selon moi l'origine de
cette injustice elle est idéologique
c'est que les gens ils ont vraiment du
mal c'est un peu de ce dont on parlait
tout à l'heure ils ont vraiment du mal à
accepter que leur comportement ils
puissent avoir des origines biologiques
même si excuse moi même s'il n'ya aucun
psychologie et psychologues
révolutionnaire qui dit
que les comportements sont déterminés
biologiquement tous les psychologues
reconnaissent la part de l'environnement
la part de la culture et c'est la seule
chose qu'on dit c'est qu'il existe
également une composante biologiques et
génétiques à un très grand nombre de
comportements
tu pense qu'il ya pas mal de gens qui
partent en fait de l'intuition sur
laquelle leur ampleur leur moral quelque
chose qui est un peu flou total qui
s'explique pas en tout cas pas par
l'évolution et qui ensuite vont sortir
un raisonnement motivés et trouver
toutes sortes d'arguments ensuite ad-hoc
pour essayer de justifier leur intuition
c'est un mois exactement si maintenant
je ne vous mets un petit peu ça donc
dans toutes les histoires que tu as
c'est cet aspect de prédictif et il ya
un côté un peu spectaculaire qui me
semble bah on veut une théorie et puis
on veut que la théorie fasse une
prédiction un peu spectaculaire pour
pouvoir être gagnant en créant son mot à
dire
est ce que c'est cette phase 2 de
prédictions se sont vraiment nécessaires
nécessaire je pense qu'elle est très
importante en fait en fait je vois pas
je vois pas comment on fait pour essayer
de donner plus de crédit à notre
hypothèse si on n'utilise pas ses
prédictions qu'elle fait sur le sur le
présent ouais parce que là c'était des
nouvelles prédictions sur détroit ne
savait pas trop mais si on avait une
théorie qui parce que moi ce qui me
frappe un peu sur ses idées
révolutionnaires
c'est que à un mythe on peut dire que
c'est des histoires mais ces crs des
histoires seront très simples et si une
histoire très simple parvient à
expliquer beaucoup de phénomènes à la
fois même si ces phénomènes sont bien
connus ça reste quelque chose de
remarquable
je trouve oui moi je suis complètement
d'accord mais quand tu dis qu'elle
permet d'expliquer beaucoup de choses en
fait tu es en train de dire qu'elle a
fait beaucoup de prédiction et que
toutes ces prédictions se sont avérées
vraies non c'est pas une autre façon a
exercé un peu sa version finale ça
revient à dire ça mais c'est pas
nécessairement des nouvelles prédictions
sur des phénomènes qu'on connaissait pas
d'accord moi je vois ce que tu veux dire
je vois ce que tu veux dire
et oui oui non mais t'as raison et c'est
d'autant plus important que c'est ce que
tu disais en fait les prédictions que tu
fais sur la psychologie
souvent elles sont pas spectaculaires
tout simplement parce que bon voilà on
st trop' spectre on a une idée un peu de
comment notre psychologie fonctionne
même si très souvent cette idée est
fausse à cause de justement tous les
biais tous les billets auxquelles il est
soumis
mais c'est vrai que c'est plus difficile
de faire des c'est probablement plus
difficile de faire des prédictions
spectaculaire en psychologie ce que dans
beaucoup de manières dans nos souvenirs
dans la manière dont beaucoup de gens
présente la méthode scientifique
il ya cette phase c'est que beaucoup de
confusion semblent considérer très
important qui est le fait d'aller tester
la théorie d'être une théorie après faut
aller tester et du coup il ya cette idée
de voix voire aller chercher de
nouvelles données pour corroborer ou
infirmer la théorie alors qu' il y avait
passé une histoire ses célèbres de
d'einstein qui a trouvé la relativité
générale
en fait il était déjà convaincu parce
qu'en fait ça c'est la théorie était la
rectifier général était une équation
remarquablement simple qui permettait
d'expliquer énormément de choses en un
sens a été plus simple que même les
équations de newton plus simple
l'équation est plus plus plus que cinq
en un sens c'est plus naturel même si
elle est montée des tensions donc c'est
un peu plus compliqué mais en un sens
c'est quand même plus simple et moins de
symboles est assez naturel et ça suffit
en fait à einstein pour convaincre
einstein avoue sans avoir besoin d'aller
chercher d'autres données pour confirmer
cette théorie
huawei je vois ce que tu veux dire juste
la simplicité la beauté du truc
ouais bah ouais mais dans un sens c'est
un peu je pense c'est aussi un peu le
cas qui se passe avec la sélection
naturelle
la sélection naturelle
tel qu'exposé par darwin se résument
elles se résument en trois phrases et
elle te permet d'expliquer l'intégralité
du vivant que c'est juste un truc de
malade comme darwin en tracts en trois
phrases
il arrive à t'expliquer pourquoi tu
regarde par la fenêtre et tu prends
n'importe quel être vivant que tu vois
par la fenêtre que ce soit un chat un
chien un chou-fleur un brin d'herbe et
darwin it it explique pourquoi tu as un
ancêtre commun avec ce brin d'herbe
pourquoi tu as un ancêtre commun avec ce
chou fleur si tu remontes suffisamment
dans les ancêtres dans tes ancêtres dans
les enseignes du chou-fleur tu vas
tomber sur l'ancêtre commun coûts et en
trois phrases il arrive at unifier tout
le vivant en fait c'est ça le truc qui
est incroyable fin que je trouve
incroyable avec la théorie de
l'évolution
je pense que ça rejoint un peu ce que tu
dis sur la beauté le caractère
unificateur de la théorie mais ricard et
non je pense que derrière darwin c'est
vraiment un exemple passé c'est une
théorie très simple qui permet de
comprendre énormément de phénomène à la
fois et j'ai envie de dire que ça ça
suffit pour avoir une grande prudence
si on arrive à faire ça donne notamment
par opposition aux autres théories de
l'époque monde pour qui c'était un peu
compliqué chaque animal était un nouvel
animal un peu plus difficile d'initier
tout ça c'est pareil pour la théorie
argumentative du raisonnement dont je te
parlais tout à l'heure
une théorie qui est aussi unificatrice
parce que qu'on avait jusqu'à présent
une liste de bié longue comme le bras
des biais de raisonnement tu peux aller
sur une patte la page wikipedia blier
biais cognitifs ou des deux
raisonnements tu vas avoir une page
d'incroyable et la théorie argumentative
du raisonnement ce qui est beau c'est
qu'elle dit non non non tout ça c'est
pas des billets ce sont des fonctions
normales du raisonnement humain quoi
qu'il arrive à donner du sens à tout un
tas de données qu'on n'arrivait pas
vraiment à expliquer avec nous
nos théories de la rationalité qu'on
avait jusque là ouais du coup est ce que
tu pense qu'il ya vraiment un problème
de avec la manière dont présente la
méthode scientifique est ce qu'il
faudrait faire plus d'efforts critiquer
un peu puis ça ben moi je suis que je
suis carrément pour emphatique si ça me
permet de me défendre contre les gens
qui attaquent la psychologie
évolutionnaire je suis carrément pour
remettre en compte remettre en cause la
dame la méthode scientifique ou la
méthode scientifique telle qu'elle est
comprise habituellement enfin ce que je
veux dire c'est que dans ma pratique tu
as dans ma pratique de la méthode
scientifique j'ai pas l'impression de
faire de la fausse science infuse
j'ai vraiment l'impression de faire de
la science qui permet de se rapprocher
de la vérité en quelque sorte
et pourtant il ya quand même des gens
qui me disent qu'ils ont l'air de dire
c'est pas de la vraie science ne sera
jamais sûr à 100% et c'est quoi ce que
pascal est intéressant c'est dans ce
podcast c'est une princesse en toutes
les personnes que j'ai interviewés à
chaque fois sauf peut-être sur
l'altruisme efficace mais à chaque fois
on a eu à un moment où on aime sûr être
efficace on a parlé on peut d des
spécificités de l'épistémologie de leur
domaine que ce soit en macroéconomie
avec avec gil rose et éthique avec avec
christophe pour le climat avec avec
rodolphe et ce avec à chaque fois en
fait on se rend compte que cette méthode
scientifique telle qu'elle est décrite
colle pas en tout cas avec les personnes
que j'interviewe est le seul cas où elle
colle vraiment avec juliette on a parlé
de de la médecine et des tests
randomisés des médicaments en fait c'est
ça semble très problématique cela semble
dur via aussi à d'autres prennent comme
le biais de publications mais il n'ya
pas que cette raison qu'en fait la
méthode scientifique telle ou telle qu
elle est souvent présentée
lorsqu'on l'appliquent vraiment bas
finalement elle assez restrictive et
et voilà c'est c'est potentiellement
limité ouais je pense que je suis
d'accord avec ça ouais donc doute
du coup on peut revenir peut-être un peu
à ta thèse du coup tu parlais de faire
des simulations oued ont quand même fait
part à dire dans la vidéo on peut re a
expliqué un petit break alors alors le
donc mois l'hypothèse que j'ai défendu
pendant ma thèse et qui est pas mon
hypothèse qui est l'hypothèse des
directeurs de des gens avec qui j'ai
travaillé de mes directeurs de thèse
c'est que la raison pour laquelle on
aurait évolué un sens moral c'est parce
que au cours de l'évolution on a été
confronté à un très gros problème de
survie qui est le problème d'être choisi
comme partenaire de coopération
donc c'est à dire si tu regardes chez
les chasseurs cueilleurs tout ce qu'ils
font toute la journée c'est de la
coopération ils vont coopérer pour aller
à la chasse pour ce pour construire des
habitations pour se défendre des
prédateurs et donc il ya un gros
problème pour la survie qui est qui et
que tu dois faire partie de ces
interactions tu dois te faire partir tu
dois te faire choisir comme partenaire
de coopération et l'hypothèse c'est que
la morale ça sert à ça ça sert à aller
contre ton égoïsme si tu veux pour te
faire choisir lors de ces interactions
pour que par exemple quand tu as à
partager un animal que tu as tué à la
chasse mais tu gardes pas tous pour toi
parce que si tu gardes tout pour toi tu
vas tu te feras plus choisir à l'avenir
comme partenaires de coopération et donc
tu va subir des coûts très importants et
donc au final tes chances de survivre
vont être diminuées donc un des trucs
que j'ai fait pendant ma thèse c'est m
c'est ce raisonnement verbal que je
viens de te dire là le essayé de le
mettre en équation et essayer de faire
des simulations aussi qui montrent que
effectivement au moins en théorie ce
genre de chose est possible que si des
individus doivent être choisis comme
partenaire de coopération au final il la
meilleure stratégie qui va être pour eux
ça va être adapté des comportements qui
ont l'air de comportements moraux ou
comportements et quidams et ben bassat
assez bien marché c'est ce que j'ai fait
ce que j'ai pu montrer dans différents
papiers que
lorsque les individus doivent être
choisis comme partenaire de coopération
ils se mettent au bout d'un moment à
évoluer des comportements de partage en
deux parts égales par exemple ou des
comportements de partage qui vont
récompenser
l'individu qui a le plus travaillé qui
sont des comportements qui ressemble
très fort aux comportements moraux que
l'on observe aujourd'hui dans l'espèce
humaine et du préfet c'est la réflexion
que du moustoir de modèles expliqué
également du coup pourquoi on serait
accro aux potins on cherchera en savoir
un peu plus sur ce qui se passe ailleurs
ouais ouais mais complètement la
réputation est vraiment très importante
dans ses modèles puisque c'est elle qui
te permet de savoir avec qui tu va
interagir ou pas par contre ce qu'on
sait pas trop si la réputation était
déjà là avant si c'était déjà si c'était
déjà très important de défendre sa
réputation ou si elle a plus ou moins qu
évolué en même temps que la morale c'est
pas très claires qui étaient là en
premier ce tube mais dans tous ses
modèles la réputation est extrêmement
importante et du coup quand avant
c'était simulation à ce que lorsque tu
lui a lancé tu t'es dit bon ça devrait
marcher ou est ce que tu dirais je sais
pas trop qui quand on a vu les résultats
que tu es c'est que ça marche et non
louey c'est ce deuxième cas c'est ce
deuxième cas en fait mon directeur de
thèse il avait déjà fait des simulations
mais dans un cadre dans un cas plutôt
simple et moi je faisais une extension
de ces résultats et on savait vraiment
pas trop si ça allait marcher
et là il ya un moment où tu regardes tes
résultats étaient vraiment juste trop
content que parce que enfin pour donner
un exemple ce que mon directeur de thèse
avait montré c'est que les individus ils
vont se mettre au bout d'un moment à
partager en deux parts égales les ce
qu'ils ont produit en coopérant donc ça
c'était un premier résultat qui est
intéressant parce que l'égalitarisme
c'est un aspect important de la morale
humaine mais mais s'était limité à ça et
moi par exemple j'ai fait d'autres
simulations qui ont montré que les
individus il allait aussi à se mettre à
dos n'est plus à leurs partenaires même
s'ils sont en position de garder tout
pour eux quand ils ont produit
quand ils ont produit des ressources en
coopérant même s'ils sont en position de
tout garder pour eux ils vont donner
plus que 50% alors à leurs partenaires
si leur partenaire a beaucoup travaillé
ça c'est vraiment un truc qui s'est
vraiment une propriété émergente des
populations c'est pas moi qui les
connaît dans mon modèle c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui émerge tout seul parce
que c'est la meilleure stratégie pour
survivre et se reproduire ça c'est
vraiment un truc c'est vraiment le bon
côté de la recherche c'est ce qu'il ya
de ce que je trouve qu'il ya de mieux
dans la recherche et du coup quand tu as
découvert ces résultats ont attaqué une
histoire derrière ça ou teaser cigéo
petit à petit non j'ai dit ouais c'est
cool et puis je passais la suite et puis
voilà maintenant pour écrire le papier
ça voilà alors moi j'ai la chance de
j'aimais bien écrit ans j'aimais bien
j'aimais bien faire des recherchés mais
j'aime bien aussi écrire des papiers ça
m'a jamais dérangé c'est parce que ce
n'est pas le cas de tout le monde donc
tout a donc peut-être défendu la thèse
et je sais pas trop quand tu as décidé
de ne pas rester dans la recherche va
essayer rester ou s'est passé après
ouais très bonne question alors ma thèse
c'est très bien passé je pense qu'il
faut que ce soit dit parce que ce n'est
pas le cas pour beaucoup de doctorants
et enfin beaucoup je sais pas que c'est
beaucoup mais j'en connais plusieurs
pour qui ça s'est pas bien passée et
souvent ça s'est pas bien passé parce
que les encadrants de thèse n'était pas
l'aura pas très sympa ou pas très
disponible
c'était pas des brancards en moi c'est
pas du tout ça ça c'est mes directeurs
de thèse était super ils m'ont laissé
beaucoup de liberté et plus de choisir
les sujets que je voulais approfondir
mon il était très présent aussi c'est
pas genre des directeurs de thèse
tu les vois une fois par mois et puis et
puis c'est tout ensuite une démo est
tout seul donc ça s'est très bien passé
ma tête j'ai réussi à publier aussi de
façon correcte des papiers et on m'a
proposé un post-doc aussi pour continuer
dans la recherche à la fin de ma thèse
mais j'ai décidé de tout plaquer en fait
de tout arrêter et il ya plusieurs
raisons à cela la première raison c'est
que je trouvais que j'étais beaucoup
trop spécialisées dans ma thèse c'est à
dire que pour être un bon chercheur
il faut vraiment être à la pointe de son
domaine
et qui pour être à la pointe de ton
domaine t'as pas le temps d'aller lire
des trucs à droite à gauche serait foutu
lit vraiment des papiers toujours sur le
même sujet et moi je me lasse assez vite
je suis à curieux un peu de tout je me
lasse assez vite et du coup ça ça me
plaisait pas trop ça c'était un premier
point deuxième point c'est que les
perspectives quand on est chercheur sont
vraiment pas très bonnes c'est à dire
que pour obtenir un poste je sais pas si
les gens qui nous écoutent connaissent
la situation mais pour obtenir un poste
qu'on pourrait qualifier de cdi comme un
poste à long terme c'est pas rare de
devoir aller faire presque dix ans de
cdd à droite à gauche tout autour du
monde parce qu'on appelle des post doc
et puis quand on revient en france it on
a la chance d'obtenir un poste c'est un
poste qui sera généralement très mal
payés enfin qui est payé qui est
vraiment le minimum
et en plus de ça le métier de chercheur
s'est enfin bon ça nous amènerait trop
loin de casillas est à spirales même
embarqué encore sur un truc différent de
la reconnaissance sociale mais ça nous
emmènerait trop loin et le troisième
point c'est que le métier de chercheur
il est il est cassé
ça c'est un point qui va s'intéresser
enfin que tu connais mais qui va qui va
dans son sens
il est cassé de l'intérieur en fait par
exemple il ya ce qu'on appelle le
publish or perish c'est à dire que quand
on est chercheur dont nous publions
publié beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
papiers parce que où c'est le système
qui nous qui nous pousse à faire ça
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on va être
évalué quand on va postuler pour avoir
un poste on va être évalué sur le nombre
de papiers leur qualité évidemment aussi
mais aussi le nombre de papiers qu'on a
pu milliers et donc ça ça pousse les
chercheurs selon moi à faire de la
quantité au détriment de la qualité
c'est à dire que dès qu'ils vont avoir
un résultat op qui vont écrire un papier
ils vont le publier et donc ils vont
faire plein de petits papiers et je
trouve que ça s'est vraiment c'est
vraiment dommage parce que ça nous
empêche en tant que chercheur de prendre
du recul sur ce qu'on fait et je trouve
que ce serait beaucoup plus intéressant
de publier un gros papier vraiment un
énorme papier tous les trois-quatre ans
plutôt que d'y papier en trois-quatre
ans offrent quand tu dis que ça va me
faire plaisir je passe un peu pour le
monstre qui aurait peut-être critiqué
les sciences à l'effet ans la méthode
scientifique telle qu'elle est pratiquée
quoi c'est une critique qui est pas qui
est très courant récurrentes je pense
que tout tout tout tout tout personne
qui a fait une thèse qui est chercheur
au moins au privé bc oui c'est un jeu je
suis ton avis je sais ce que je suis en
train de dire c'est exactement ça qui
est ça il ya le publish or perish à la
crise de réplicabilité alors pour ceux
qui sont pas au courant et des
chercheurs qui sont arrivés dans les
années 2000 et qui nous ont dit bon ben
en fait pour des raisons variées
soixante pour cent de tous les résultats
scientifiques qui ont été publiés sont
faux vote arrive là dedans tu es un
petit doctorants qui veut bien faire tu
voyages écrite faire la recherche il
veut trouver des trucs et puis on te dit
que tout ce qui a été fait pas tout ce
qui a été fait mais une grande majorité
de ce qui a été fait avant toi est faux
et ça ça te fout vraiment un coup énorme
au moral quoi c'est pas facile
le temps est ton propre travail en fait
comme ton propre travail il est basé sur
des méthodes qu'on nous apprend et qui
sont en place depuis des années
ça veut dire qu'il ya aussi une très
forte chance que ton propre travail soit
faux quoi mais c'est un autre tract
fuite à pied sur un tapis sur des trucs
qu'on fait d'autres personnes et que tu
pouvais pas le genre des simulations
c'est peut-être tout codé de a à z ou
est-ce que ouais j'ai tout codé de la
zen mais pour générer certaines de mes
hypothèses je m'appuie sur des données
je vais pas fixer simule pendant ma
thèse en fait j'ai eu et j'ai eu une
partie théorique simulation et une
partie expérimentale où j'allais faire
des partages d'argent par exemple entre
gens c'est un truc qui se fait beaucoup
en économie comportementale
je donne de l'argent c'est vraiment tout
simple je donne de l'argent à des gens
et puis je regarde dans différentes
conditions comment ils vont partager
donc ça c'est vraiment des méthodes de
psychologie et d'économie qui sont qui
ont été remises en question par ses
papiers dont je parle quoi sur la
réplicabilité et donc tu as arrêté la
recherche et du coup tu fais quoi voilà
moi j'ai décidé d'arrêter la recherche
en tenant pardon je reprends j'ai décidé
d'arrêter la recherche académique c'est
à dire la recherche dans le système quoi
par contre mon but à la fin de ma tête
c'était de continuer à faire de la
recherche mais comme comme un hobby quoi
parce que l'activité de recherche est
génial ce qui est ce qui est nul c'est
le système vraiment donc je voulais
continuer à faire de la recherche comme
un hobby sans être payés pour faire de
la recherche sans être attaché un labo
et pouvoir gagner ma vie à côté de ça en
faisant d'autres activités moi j'ai
choisi la programmation en particulier
parce que c'est un truc qui permet de
bien gagner sa vie sans trop beau c'est
ça laisse pas mal de temps et je voulais
recentrer aussi et je voulais faire
beaucoup plus de vulgarisation aussi
voilà j'en faisais déjà pendant ma tête
j'en faisais pendant mon master mais je
voulais aussi recentrer une grosse
partie de mon temps et mon énergie
disponible sur la vulgarisation qui
contiennent un blog à dalet a commencé
avec un blog qui s'appelle homophobie
luce way exactement et g
j'ai lancé j'ai démarré une chaîne
youtube en master mais gelé tout de
suite arrêté parce que je voulais me
consacrer à ma thèse je voulais vraiment
être 100% sur ma thèse et ensuite j'ai
redémarré après ma thèse avec une chaîne
de vulgarisation un dessin qui s'appelle
la main baladeuse mais qui aujourd'hui
en dormance on va dire ça veut dire ça
comme si elle aimait surtout une chaîne
qui s'appelle homo fabulous qui
vulgarise le comportement humain
vu par le prisme de la biologie et des
sciences cognitives
donc c'est vraiment je veux vraiment
essayé de vulgariser cette discipline
qui est pas très connu en france et pas
très populaire pour montrer que on peut
comprendre les l'humain comme un animal
réellement et que le comportement humain
c'est le produit des influences
culturelles mais également le produit de
la biologie voilà le produit de somme le
résultat de ce processus d'évolution et
de processus de sélection naturelle et
comment tu as essayé de défoncer la
vulgarisation c'est en tout cas c'est
une motivation particulier et ben ouais
je me rappelle c'est juste là c'est
juste l'émerveillement fait pendant mon
master jai lu un blog de psychologie
évolutionnaire et j'ai eu ce sentiment
le sense of wonder comme dirait le
collègue vie des as et g et voilà quand
tu ressens ce sentiment en fait je
trouve qu'il ya un autre truc que tu
ressens en même temps c'est que tu as
envie de le faire partager votre envie
de transmettre ce sentiment
d'émerveillement et c'est à partir de ce
moment là que j'ai décidé d'ouvrir ce
blog et puis en même temps si j'aime
bien ça j'aime bien jeune j'aime bien
j'aime bien transmettre
et puis vulgariser ça permet aussi
beaucoup d'apprendre ça je pense que
tous les to les vulgarisateurs le dire
on est tous les profs d'ailleurs aussi
le diront c'est que quand tu doit
enseigner quelque chose tu apprends
également tu apprends beaucoup de choses
en même temps avant de revenir en dire
un peu plus sur mon par un complice de
vulgarisation bien toi mais donc donc tu
fais encore de la recherche en hobby
castille questions qui fâchent et bepa
pas vraiment en fait c'est un des trucs
que j'ai que j'ai pas encore réussi
réellement affaire s'est dégagé un petit
peu de temps pour continuer à faire de
la recherche
j'en ai fait un tout petit peu j'ai fini
des papiers par exemple que j'avais fait
pendant ma thèse mais pour l'instant
j'ai pas encore réussi à faire ça je ne
désespère pas je suis encore en contact
avec mes directeurs de tests par exemple
je pense continuer à faire des choses
avec eux mais l'a pour l'instant j'ai
besoin de dégager du temps que la
vulgarisation ça me prend beaucoup trop
de temps plus plus la programmation en
plus je vais encore d'autres trucs à
côté qui sont qui sont pas intellectuel
on va dire puisque je ne suis je suis
pas qu'un qu'un cerveau je veux six ans
mais aussi du du sport de la musique des
conneries comme ça donc tout ça ça prend
du temps mais je ne désespère pas de me
remettre parce que c'est
c'est vraiment une activité qui donne du
sens à sa vie
nous on revient à vulgarisation puisque
t'es pas n'importe quelle ville car les
acteurs du web
monsieur et président du café des
sciences tu peux présenter un petit peu
café des sciences et ouais c'est une
association qui existe depuis plus de
dix ans maintenant et qui regroupe des
vulgarisateurs du web donc pas que des
vidéastes
on a aussi des blogueurs des
dessinateurs des gens qui font du
podcast audio
est ce qu'on fait bas on est surtout
connu pour notre site internet donc on a
un site qui est café tirer sciences.org
sur lequel on regroupe toutes les
productions de nos vulgarisateur et il
faut savoir toutes ses productions elles
ont été évaluées enfin les productions
ont pas été évoluer évaluer une par une
mais les producteurs de tous nos membres
ont été évalués sur la sur différents
critères mais notamment le critère de
qualité scientifique
donc si jamais vous allez sur ce site
web vous pouvez être relativement
confiant que vous n'allez pas lire ou
entendre d
des bêtises des bêtises énorme donc on a
sur notre site web et puis à côté de ça
on n'organise pas mal de francs décide
d'organiser des événements d on a fait
un festival il ya deux trois ans la cité
des sciences on a publié un bouquin de
tous ensemble et voilà
et puis il ya aussi ça a aussi un côté
c'est une asso cas un côté je pense que
tu peux en parler quasiment mieux que
moi parce que tu es moi je suis un peu
toujours à l'étranger à droite à gauche
mais toi tu as eu l'occasion surtout
dernièrement de d'être dans ce milieu là
c'est c'est une bonne ambiance quoi
c'est aussi un groupe de copains et de
copines qui qui se retrouvent ensemble
qu'ils ont les mêmes centres d'intérêts
même s'il y en a qui sont aussi géologue
et sexy serrer un peu particulier mais
voilà c'est aussi c'est aussi une feinte
l'aspect bande de copains copines et est
important dans cette association
c'est une saison très très très simple
en effet comment ton arrivée à devenir
président du café des sciences
[Musique]
j'avais j'avais juste envie de
investir en fait à la fin de ma thèse je
ça faisait partie de ceux de cette
transition que je voulais faire d'un
métier très de treize chercheurs très
basé sur la recherche a un métier plus
générale de chercheurs vulgarisateur
programmeurs et donc je me suis dit bon
allez je vais consacrer quelques heures
par semaine pour le bien commun
il se trouvait qu'à cette même époque le
dit le président sortant qui était alan
bonne vingtaine de dépôts de kassian
s'en aller donc je me suis dit bon allez
hop pourquoi pas on y va on est content
de son travail
l'as bien ouais ouais c'est pas c'est
pas trop c'est pas trop à moi de
répondre à la question de si je fais du
bon travail mais ouais c'est ça va quoi
j'ai fait j'avais des projets quand je
suis devenu président et je les ai
presque tous se remplit aujourd'hui donc
ça va et puis c'est vraiment une
association qui en grosse croissance
aussi qu'en juillet quand je suis devenu
président je sais plus combien en été
mais on devait être 30 40 membres un
truc comme ça aujourd'hui
notamment parce qu'il ya plein de
vidéastes qui nous ont rejoints on est
plus de plus de deux cents 200 ans et on
commence vraiment à être contactés par
différents instituts d'institutions à
droite à gauche à gauche pour être
partenaire de festivals donc s'agrandit
beaucoup alors ni beaucoup et c'est cool
ça pose aussi des défis parce qu'il faut
se structurer
ce sera aussi vraiment génial qu'on
puisse
payer quelqu'un avoir quelqu'un qui
s'occupe par exemple de toute la
paperasse ou de s'occupe de trouver des
sponsors qui s'occupe de la
communication
pour l'instant tout repose vraiment sur
le bénévolat mais voilà il ya pas mal
c'est quand même pas mal quand on a déjà
fait pas mal de choses et il ya pas mal
de défis qui arrive à l'avenir donc
c'est assez simple du coup quels sont
les projets en ce moment du café des
sciences et qu'est ce qu'on a comme
projet on a un projet mais qui n'est pas
ouvert au grand public ces de se
rassembler tous ensemble cet été la
grosse partie non pas du tout ce sera
rassemblement de travail nous ferons du
brainstorming
toute la journée les réfléchir ouais
mais le but justement et c'est un but
social mais c'est aussi un but pour
essayer de faire des choses tester des
nouvelles manières de vulgariser donc ce
serait vraiment cool qui est des choses
qui sortent de ce rassemblement complice
faire des collaborations entre
dessinateurs et vidéaste dessinateur
blogueurs on va devoir faut qu'on
réfléchisse à tout ça est en fait ce
qu'on fait alors moi je trouve que ce
que le passé nous a appris c'est que on
n'est pas vraiment fait pour organiser
nous-mêmes des événements par exemple le
festival vidéo science on l'a organisé
en partenariat avec la cité des sciences
mais ça ça nous demandent vraiment
beaucoup de temps beaucoup de travail
beaucoup d'énergie à investir moi je
trouve qu'on est une association qui est
beaucoup plus structurée pour intervenir
et animer un festival mais pas organiser
le festival à part entière et donc c'est
ce qu'on a fait dernièrement et je pense
que c'est là dessus qu'il faut axer nos
efforts à l'avenir donc par exemple
on est intervenu pour faire un stand au
festival play azur à nice n'est pas très
longtemps qui était d'ailleurs le sgt
c'était bien c'était très simple très
très cool l'absence du président pc on
se permet tout et n'importe quoi faites
gaffe gdg quand même des rapporteurs qui
leur fait confiance
mais ouais voilà on intervient tous les
gens d'ailleurs s'il ya des gens qui
nous et qui nous écoutent qui font un
festival qui organise un festival
quelque part en france
n'hésitez pas à nous contacter voilà
sachant que comme d'habitude si jamais
les ce qu'on fait peut être au moins
défrayer si ce n'est rémunéré c'est
toujours mieux quoi puisque dans la
vulgarisation c'est toujours un peu ça
le problème
beaucoup de beaucoup de bonne volonté et
beaucoup de demandes mais très peu de
moyens notamment financiers
ouais elle parle aussi de défis à venir
pour café des sciences bas les pour moi
le principal défi c'est vraiment notre
taille
c'est vraiment il faut qu'on essaie de
pas de pas s'écrouler sous notre masse
en quelques sorte parce que tu vois là
on est un bureau on est un bureau de 4
400 personnes et gérer les 200 personnes
200 membres 400 personnes bénévoles qu
on a tous un travail à côté évidemment
ça a commencé un petit peu difficile et
j'ai fait des demandes de financement
par exemple pour essayer d'avoir un
petit peu de sous voilà pour essayer
d'améliorer notre quotidien peut être
embaucher quelqu'un mais le problème
c'est que non on est encore une petite
asso donc c'est très très dur pour nous
d'obtenir des financements
en gros pour obtenir des financements
les gens ils font plus confiance au
groupe dassault mais pour être une
grosse assaut il faut déjà avoir eu des
financements
donc on est dans un espèce de cercle
vicieux la de serpent qui se mord la
queue où on
on a un peu du mal commencé à devenir
plus professionnel ça je pense que ce
sera ça va être un gros défi pour
l'avenir et n'a pas réussi de relations
avec d'autres institutions
ouais on est contacté on est contacter
régulièrement pour intervenir donc
donc il ya les festivals je sais pas si
tu appelles ça une institution mais on
est de contacter souvent par des
festivals à une époque on était en
contact avec le ministère aussi de
l'éducation et de la recherche éducation
nationale ils étaient intéressés pour
créer enfin on leur avait soumis l'idée
c'est nous qui avions soumis l'idée avec
thomas durand de la tronche en biais de
créer un prix de la vulgarisation
scientifique qui viendrait par exemple
mettre en avant la bonne vulgarisation
bonne vulgarisation entre guillemets en
tout cas qui viendrait mettre en avant
les bonnes pratiques et le ministère lui
ce qui le préoccupait c'était tout ce
qui est fake news enfin c'était déjà il
ya trois ans un sujet un petit peu
d'actualité un sujet baisse de ça l'est
toujours aujourd'hui il est le ministère
et voilà il cherchait des moyens de
lutter contre tous les gens qui font la
vulgarisation mais de la vulgarisation
de fait guy nude et nous on avait
proposé par exemple l'idée de faire un
prix comme je suis pas la cérémonie des
oscars où le festival de cannes on
viendrait remettre des récompenses avec
un jury prestigieux
enfin voilà ils nous ont pas recontacté
c'est un truc qui est c'est assez dur de
travailler avec les institutions de mon
point de vue il
on a fait deux réunions au ministère et
puis ensuite on n'a jamais une nouvelle
peu qu'on en a les seins on a laissé
tomber
on a beau rester un peu avec l'âme steve
qui est le regroupement des des
institutions de médiation et culture
scientifique en france donc des centres
de sciences des musées etc
pareille chose qui les intéresse
beaucoup c'est d'essayer de mettre en
relation
donc ces institutions classiques delà de
la médiation de la vulgarisation les
musées les centres de sciences et les la
nouvelle vague entre guillemets de la
vulgarisation enfin en gros les les gens
qui opèrent sur le web les vidéastes et
c est le but de l'injustice est entre
autres de mettre de mettre en contact
ces gens et que des collaborations
puisse avoir lieu évidemment le café des
sciences par sa position et d'un
interlocuteur idéal pour parler de ce
genre de choses mais pareil pour
l'instant c'est un projet qui est
retombée je sais pas où ils en sont de
leur côté mais nous ont pas contactés
donc voilà on a des contacts rien de
concret pour l'instant mais on continue
à explorer à voir ce qu'on vous propose
et du coup quand tu vois l'avenir du
café des sciences
ils sont cinq ans ils ont tous un terme
dans cinq ans je pense que les géologues
auront pris le pouvoir
ouais ouais c'est vraiment dur intérieur
5,5 en quoi il ya cinq ans comme je te
dis à cinq ans on était 20 30 à
l'association je suis pas sûr qu'on
aurait pu prévoir une telle évolution y
tue les futurs éducatif exister
essentiellement pas moi je pense qu'on
va continuer on va juste continuer à
grossir si on arrive à garder cette
bonne ambiance je pense que la bonne
ambiance est très importante si on
arrive à conserver cette ambiance ça va
continuer à grossir
j'espère que l'on va pas s'écrouler sur
notre propre poids comme je te disais
que si on continue à grandir et que le
bureau reste aussi limité en personnel
et en moyens financiers
je ne sais pas comment ça va se passer
et puis ce qui serait génial c'est qu'on
ait la confiance d'une grosse
institution voilà qui nous suivent
jusqu'au bout sur un sur un projet voilà
donc je vais te dire dans cinq ans on a
notre propre ministère l'espérer ça les
mystères de la vulgarisation ce serait
quand même c'est pas mal mais ça serait
pas mal ça serait prêt à savourer dans
50 du coût puisque notre truc que dante
a pas mal parlé à s'est fait que café
des sciences grossit pas mal et donc il
ya cette phase de ces deux sélections
pour les nouveaux entrants qu'en fait il
qu'ils votent pour parler - wall du café
des sciences
mais bon le nombre gossip beaucoup et je
passion on commence à perdre un peu
enfin moi je commence à perdre un point
de vue l'ensemble du café après il ya un
peu un noyau dur qui se retrouvent
souvent pour les apéros à paris mais du
coup tu es ce que tu as peur que ça
s'écoute en vrai comment est-ce qu'on
peut gérer cette croissance est ce qu'il
y a pas un risque de tu veux dire que
par exemple il ya un noyau qui continue
à être le noyau et les autres ils
n'arrivent pas à s'intégrer ou un truc
j'imagine que c'est un risque potentiel
par exemple moi je
je ne pense pas que c'est un risque de
mon expérience dans les nouveaux
entrants il ya toujours des gens qui
sont qui s'intègrent pas beaucoup mais
c'est passé pâques on les rejette c'est
juste qu'ils habitent à l'autre bout de
la france où qu'ils ont juste pas le
temps d'avoir une vie associative très
animé mais il ya des nouveaux entrants
qui tout de suite sont intégrés aux
apéros à paris par exemple
donc tant qu'on arrive à trouver
débarrasser gants pour nous accueillir à
paris on arrivera à exister
non je suis pas le savoir je suis pas
tout je suis pas trop pessimiste sur ce
point c'est vraiment plus l'aspect
paperasse et gestion de l'association
qui me fait peur mais plus que l'aspect
du social il serait temps d'embaucher
quelqu'un bas ce serait génial ce serait
génial
il serait temps d'embaucher quelqu'un à
quoi faut trouver l'argent qu'est-ce que
tu en sais gré de la communauté du café
des sciences bon prix que tu pouvais que
ces gens cool mais qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait de mal et qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait lui faire ou là je réfléchis je
ne sais pas si on fait vraiment des
choses mal parce qu'on a on a quand même
on a quand même dix ans d'existence donc
on a vraiment voilà on a eu le temps de
réfléchir par contre ya peut-être des
choses qu'on pourrait faire mieux
par exemple il ya des débats qu'on a
souvent c'est à quel point on doit
intervenir quand un vulgarisateur web
soit se prend un gros shit storm sur
twitter par exemple soit lance lui-même
un cheese terme sur twitter que c'est à
dire que notre association elle évalue
sur la qualité scientifique des contenus
mais elle évalue aussi de façon plus ou
moins ouvertes de façon plus ou moins
avoué sur cet aspect humain des
vulgarisateurs sur le fait que mais
voilà faut essayer de ne pas être trop
des gros connard et essayer de de se
contrôler sur les réseaux sociaux etc
et c'est assez dur du coup quand il ya
un événement comme ça qui se produit sur
les réseaux sociaux de savoir si on doit
intervenir en tant qu'association ou pas
si on nous positionner parce que dans un
sens voilà c'est dans un sens et le but
du café de promouvoir la bonne
vulgarisation donc par exemple qui
devrait pouvoir donner son avis
il rappelait alors notre lit mais pas de
façon méchante mais rappeler à l'ordre
un de ses membres
mais d'un autre côté voilà les membres
ils sont aussi libres ont fait signer
aucune charte à personne aimant mais ils
sont libres de dire ce qu'ils veulent et
ils peuvent faire des erreurs également
ça arrive de faire des erreurs
il ya ce côté là un kippour qui pourrait
être amélioré
je le sais pas trop tu me parle
d'améliorations récemment ça me fait
penser que la au mois de janvier il ya
quelqu'un qui a déposé une motion à
l'association pour que soient acceptés
les sciences au sens large donc sciences
dites dures entre guillemets et sciences
humaines et sociales alors jusqu'à
présent on l'est on les accepte et aussi
on ne les exclut est pas mais on disait
qu'on accepte et les sciences humaines
et sociales uniquement si elle portait
sur un sujet scientifique c'est à dire
les par exemple la philosophie des
sciences les gens qui faisaient de la
philosophie des sciences où les gens qui
faisaient des sciences sociales qui
étudié la façon dont les chercheurs
travaillent par exemple on accepter ces
personnes monsieur fille aussi mon
monsieur fils moi je trouve que sa
chaîne c'est faux que je fasse gaffe à
ce que je dis quoi mais monsieur fille
pour moi sa chaîne c'est de la science
donc ça fait pas partie des faits ça
fait même pas partie de la si je devais
dire si c'est de la science ou de la
philo sa chaîne j'aurais vraiment du mal
à apprécier quand il faudrait vraiment
me mettre un pistolet sur la tempe livre
pouvoir dessiner quoi pour moi je le
trouve beaucoup plus scientifique que
certains autres membres où certains
autres vulgarisateur qui eux vulgarise
la biologie ou des trucs comme ça moi je
veux dire dans ses raisonnements danser
danser dans ses explications et du coup
je vis ton était et est encore un
scientifique arrêtera pas droit de faire
ça j'entends la façon de produire de la
connaissance principalement c'est ce à
quoi c'est à dire que quand ils nous
présentent à ce sujet il va vraiment
présenter tout le raisonnement qui amène
à une conclusion est souvent quand il
fait des faq il explique pourquoi les
raisonnements des gens dans les
commentaires n'ont pas l'air très
sérieux et dans un sens je trouve qu'il
fait parfois un boulot ce décès pains et
éthicien et se déclare pas comme ça et
éthicien il y pas qu'il est une chaîne d
et éthiques
mais dans un sens que je trouve que
quand il fait ça quand il explique ses
raisonnements la façon dont ils pensent
ou la façon dont il faut penser un sujet
il fait un boulot qui est même presque
mieux que le boulot de certains et
éthicien quoi parce qu'il montre
vraiment des cas concrets dans lesquels
dans lesquels il faut impliquer la
pensée rationnelle ou le bon
raisonnement c'est un peu ce que disait
christophe michel dans la vidéo que tu
as fait avec lui il ya trois semaines
vous disais qu il ya beaucoup d et
éthicien qui parle de zététique mais qui
la pratiquent pas du tout et je trouve
que monsieur fif fait beaucoup ça et
c'est ça qui me fait dire que c'est
ces vidéos sont scientifiques et en plus
de ça il ya les sujets qui choisit aussi
qui sont des sujets quand même
relativement scientifique
quand il parle de conscience quand il
parle de réalisme scientifiquement
évidemment tout ça tout ça c'est en
plein dans la science ou mais au-delà de
ça même quand il parle de sujets qui
sont pas vraiment scientifique a la base
je trouve que dans les raisonnements qui
propose ça reste scientifique je sais
pas si ça te satisfait comme réponse et
du coup c'est très centré sur le
raisonnement le la qualité des arguments
de la clarté de la démarche
ouais où je pense que c'est ça je pense
que c'est quelque chose qui quelques
thèmes racon med top pas mal en avant
dans le café licenciement doit
ouais ouais ouais en fait si tu me
demandes
ouais je pense qu'il faudrait mettre sa
plus en avant les sites si tu me
demander par exemple de je sais que
c'est un truc que tu fais à la fin et du
coup tu trouveras une autre question si
tu me demandait de citer un vidéaste de
vulgarisation scientifique
je n'insiste pas de philosophie il ya
une probabilité importante que je cite
monsieur fixe et un premier tu vas au
1er juillet au lieu de science étonnante
au lieu de retomber l'îlot dix autres
comme ça et en plus il a une approche
tellement rafraîchissant bhl de la
philosophie qui est tellement différente
de la philosophie qu'on nous a enseigné
au lycée
voilà pour moi c'est là c'est de la
philosophie scientifique ce qui fait
quoi et c'est pour ça que je dis que
c'est de la science ok d'autres choses
qu'on pourrait mieux faire d'autres
choses qu'on pourrait mieux faire
alors ouais juste pour conclure là
dessus donc tout ça c'était pour dire ça
fait encore une grosse digressions que
on s'est amélioré au moins sur un point
puisqu'il ya un membre qui nous a fait
remarquer qu'il trouvait que la
formulation qu'on avait sur les sciences
sociales c'est à dire qu'on accepte les
sciences sociales que si elle traite de
science voilà de façon plus ou moins
éloignées c'était un peu discriminatoire
ou je sais pas ça les embêter un peu les
dons qu'ils ont proposé une motion pour
enlever ce passage là et donc depuis
janvier là on accepte toutes les
sciences sans exception qu elle soit
sciences dures qu'elles soient sciences
humaines et sociales
à condition qu'elle faisait qu'elle soit
alors on a une formulation sur lesquels
on a débattu je crois qu'on a dit on
accepte toutes les sciences en gros
temps qu'elles sont de qualité fois
qu'on a dit un truc comme ça quoi c'est
à dire que c'est à dire que les sciences
humaines et sociales
on va leur appliquer on va leur demander
un niveau d'exigence qui le même que le
niveau d'exigence qu'on demanderait pour
de la biologie de la physique mais ça
faisait penser à une autre
un autre remarque que je me fais parfois
c'est que nathan sa classe et
la qualité des des recherches de
vulgarisation en fonction du sujet
qu'elle traite
ouais alors que j'en veux dire que tu
tout sujet est potentiellement
intéressante pourvu qu'il est traité
avec rigueur
attention avec prise en compte des
données empiriques et tout ça ouais
ouais du coup de bâton c'est à dire que
ce qui ce qui ce qui est important c'est
pas tellement le sujet traité mais plus
sa manière dont il est traité
ouais c'est ça l'angle qu'on a adopté
mais est ce que tu pourrais pas dire
quand même qu'il ya certains sujets qui
sont plus plus difficiles que d'autres
parce qu'ils sont plus complexes
typiquement l'humain tu vois les
sciences humaines
on pense que c'est c'est très compliqué
parce qu'un humain à la base c'est très
compliqué et puis après quand tu
rajoutes des dizaines de couches de
culture d'éducation etc
ça devient vraiment un système complexe
incroyable qu'est ce que tu reviendras
qu'il est quand même des domaines qui
sont intrinsèquement plus compliqué
m'bow week l'a fait clairement il est
clairement le voyez sur l'image
c'est très simple c'est ça que je
voulais dire il m'a t il très simple
avec dès qu'on passe des trucs humains
ou les trucs en économie est fréquent en
environnement système ultra complexes
mais du coup alors il ya toujours moyen
de traiter ces problèmes avec lui peu
probable en vue que le sujet est plus
complexe on ira avec beaucoup plus de
valider il faudrait y aller avec plus de
modestie systémique et de de plusieurs
hypothèses
à considérer plusieurs façons
d'interpréter les données ainsi de suite
alors que dans des sujets plus simple en
maths on peut juste et non c'est un
théorème est la preuve
mais ça ça n'empêche pas que le sujet
puisse être traité de façon tout cas
avec un maximum de deux d'attention de
rigueur et de bienveillance aussi c'est
pas tellement guéret au silence algérie
ouais ben non mais j'ai complètement
d'accord avec toi sur ce point les
dépenses c'est pour ça que c'est aussi
pour ça que j'étudie le l'humain le
cerveau humain c'est parce que c'est un
défi énorme
c'est un des plus gros défi pour la
science au 21ème siècle à mon avis que
comprendre comment le cerveau humain
fonctionne avec peut-être les
intelligences artificielles ou je sais
pas quoi mais du court et je trouve ça
je trouve ça sympa d'essayer de relever
ce défi tous ensemble seront bien les
branches ne pas jurer donc est encore
sorti au moment d'enregistrer sa mais
aussi l'interview j'ai fait deux de
rodolphe où il parle de l'environnement
et d'environnement est incroyablement
complexe que ces genres et puis c'est un
défi énorme en plus tout à fait aimer
c'est d'autant plus important je dirais
comme le sujet complexe est d'autant
plus important de faire attention à la
méthode et aux méthodes qu'on va
utiliser pour traiter ces problèmes
exactement d'autres choses qu'on pourra
faire mieux
ça fait trois fois déjà d'autres choses
qu'on pourrait faire mieux bah gpat à
des trucs à me proposer par exemple ça
m'intéresse moi c'est un des trucs à un
propos du jeu posé des questions 1
question l'idée je repartirai qu'une
autre question désolé il y aura fait
qu'elles sont des débats récurrents sans
du café débat récurrent alors
donc on a eu ce débat un peu sur les
sciences sociales qui revenait
régulièrement c'est arrivé maintenant il
a l'air d'être réglée tant mieux encore
que c'est peut-être convard changer la
formulation débat récurrent à temps il y
en a pas ce que sur la sur un autre
débat intéressant c'est sur les critères
de vote alors le ce qui s'est passé
c'est que pendant longtemps on a voté
avec nos tripes entre guillemets donc
les critères de vote je parle des votes
quand quand quelqu'un candidate pour
devenir membre du café des sciences on
va faire ce dont on parlait tout à
l'heure donc un vote pour savoir s'il
doit être accepté ou pas et pendant très
longtemps on a voté avec nos tripes
c'est à dire qu'on n'avait pas vraiment
de critères on allait regarder le blog
ou la chaîne vidéo de cette personne et
puis on disait oui ou non
en gros et puis il ya des gens qui ont
dit c'est vraiment faim ce serait bien
qu'on se dote de critères quoi qu'on
soit un peu tous sur le même plan pour
faire c'est pour faire ces votes qu' il
n'y a pas d'injustice entre différents
candidats qui sont évalués et c'est à
dire donc aussi un candidat par exemple
ils nous disent pourquoi
pourquoi j'ai été rejetée qu'on ait
vraiment des réponses à lui apporter
quoi qu'on lui qu'on lui donne des
critères et qu'on ne dise pas juste
c'est comme ça et les membres ont voté
contre
donc suite à ça on ne j'ai lancé c'était
plus trois quatre ans j'ai lancé eiffage
et j'ai sondé les membres du café des
sciences sur tout un tas de critères qui
penseraient intéressant et on s'est doté
d'une de critères qui sont présents sur
d'autres sites web sur lesquels on est
censé se baser pour faire nos votes mais
il ya des gens qui qui continue à penser
le contraire qui continue à penser que
les critères que si on a des critères en
fait il ya quasiment plus besoin de
voter quoi si tu as des critères tu as
juste à cocher si la personne elle est
allée dans les critères et puis voilà ça
sert à rien de voter une seule personne
pourrait faire le classement situe donc
il ya un débat depuis c'est un débat qui
revient régulièrement sur est-ce qu'on
doit se doter de critères ou pas la
question de quels sont ces critères et
je pense assez réglé on a réussi à se
mettre d'accord assez facilement mais
d'explosifs 21 bas il y en a plusieurs
lequel les critère le plus important
évidemment c'est laquelle la qualité
scientifique du contenu pas de pseudo
sciences etc mais aussi des critères sur
la forme donc si c'est un blog ça doit
être écrit enfin ça doit être lisible
si c'est une chaîne vidéo la technique
doit être à peu près bonne et s'est
récemment
thiam a encore un débat qui est apparue
cet hiver c'est le débat sur est-ce
qu'on doit forcer les candidats est ce
qu'on doit mettre comme critère que les
vidéos doivent être sous titré que pour
qu'un vidéaste intègre le café des
sciences ces vidéos doivent être sous
titré dans un dans une perspective de
d'accessibilité pour et on a fait un
vote là dessus aussi parce que il ya eu
un petit peu de débat mais en fait tout
le monde était d'accord
quasiment tout le monde passait le
résultat du vote c'est 80 90 % les gens
disent qu'il faut pas forcer les
candidats a sous titré leurs vidéos mais
qu'il faut leur recommander très
fortement de le faire voilà et a
contrario on a vraiment c'est les
critères sont très variées la présence
de pub par exemple je crois que c'est un
critère qui a été voté comme pas
important donc tu as le droit de
soumettre bas typiquement une chaîne
youtube avec avec des publicités ou un
blog avec des publicités
ce sera c'est pas important pour nous
quand on prendra pas en compte ce
critère là et mais après ça voilà on a
des critères mais c'est des critères qui
reste subjectif dans un sens parce que
même un critère comme
avoir une bonne orthographe pour les
blogs écrits c'est quelque chose qui est
assez assez subjectif qu'est ce que
c'est une bonne orthographe qu il y aura
différents niveaux il y aura différents
niveaux donc pour l'instant on a des
critères mais on continue à tous voter
et on espère que l'agrégation de tous
ces votes formera quelque chose d'à peu
près qui a du sens là bas sinon provenir
la question qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire mieux j'ai réfléchi un petit peu à
quelques quelques points tu me dis ce
que tu en penses
en fait c'est plus des questions jusqu'à
pas d'heure je peux oublier ce que tu
penses que le niveau de rigueur qu'on a
au café est trop élevée ou pas assez
élevé l'exigence de rigueur
ouais je pense je pense que elle est
suffisamment élevé parce qu'on a jamais
eu de problème de deux membres qui soit
acceptée et qui plus tard se mettra à
publier n'importe quoi tu roules on n'a
jamais de deux membres qui s'est
transformé en gourou des pseudosciences
d'un seul coup comme ça je vais dire ça
fait que le cnrs
voilà c'est ça exactement donc ça c'est
quand même pas mal passé quand même
ville une bonne une bonne indication que
ça marche plus ou moins qu'on arrive à
éliminer les pseudosciences et les gens
pas sérieux et maintenant dans l'autre
sens est-ce que c'est le critère sont
trop élevés jeu aurait tendance à dire
non après c'est peut-être du
raisonnement motivé parce que parce que
voilà j'ai pas envie de d'avouer que
quand on a des problèmes et je ne sais
pas j'ai pas par exemple j'ai jamais eu
cette remarque ça fait plusieurs années
que je suis au café des sciences il n'ya
jamais aucun membre qu'on a rejeté qui
dit
qui nous aide qui nous dit que vous avez
des critères trop important alors il ya
un type une fois il nous a dit qu'on
était trop élitiste mais c'était pour
une raison précise
et je les oublier mais il ya un type il
ya un type une fois il a lu nos
commentaires parce qu'en fait quand on
vote on demande aux membres de laisser
des commentaires qu'on puisse pour qu'on
puisse les transmettre aux candidats
ensuite qu'ils avaient acceptée ou non
est un type on l'a accepté et on lui a
transmis les commentaires et il a eu les
commentaires
et en lisant les commentaires il s'est
dit bon mais ça m'intéresse plus de
rejoindre rejoindre le café des sciences
et je crois que la justification qui
donnait c'était vous êtes trop élitiste
mais je me rappelle plus de la raison
exacte
ok je vais essayer de nous le rappeler
mais sinon une autre réflexion c'est sûr
bador je te poser la question à toi est
ce que tu fait relire t script ouais je
fais relire mes scripts parme des
experts par des chercheurs en fait à
chaque fois que je ne suis je me
considère pas moi-même experts c'est à
dire quasiment tout le temps mais par
exemple sur ma vidéo sur la morale des
animaux je n'ai pas fait relire pages
les ferrière par personne mais sinon
ouais c'est un décès un d un des piliers
en gros de mon travail qui est de faire
en sorte que tous mes scripts soir lui
ce que je fais si je les envoie pour
l'instant j'ai réussi à trouver des
experts qui était dans mes contacts donc
ça c'est un gros avantage d'avoir fait
une thèse d'avoir d'avoir traîné dans
les labos sais que j'ai des contacts
denses et la vo et je sais qui je peux
contacter ça c'est pour les gens qui
sont extérieurs je crois que tant parlé
avec gilles de rais cas c'est un peu dur
de savoir parfois de qui contacter sur
un sujet mois en général je le sais où
si je le sais pas en envoyant des emails
je vais je vais savoir qui je peux
contacter et je lui ai je le fais
notamment parce que si roman fabulous je
parle de sujets qui sont je parle de
recherche qui est en train de se faire
c'est un peu ça aussi ce que je veux
faire avec ma chaîne s'est présentée de
la recherche qui est en train de se
faire et souvent ils souvent alors j'ai
pas trop encore fait mais je vais de
plus en plus présente et de la recherche
qui est politiquement incorrect la
recherche un peu controversé et c'est
pour ça que je me sers 10 heures c'est
pour ça que j'ai vraiment besoin de
faire rire mes scripts pour être le plus
inattaquable possible même si je sais
que voilà il peut toujours que je passe
à côté de quelque chose quoi etc et mais
c'est désormais en fait ouais les
sorties à faire des vidéos etc oui et
non mais en fait quand tu fais de la
psychologie de la psychologie
évolutionnaire elle n'a pas de
difficulté à reconnaître qu'il existe
des différences psychologiques entre
individus c'est en fait c'est une
conséquence toute simple de l'évolution
l'évolution c'est de la variation les
individus sont différents et c'est ce
qu'on sait en fait on le sait déjà il ya
déjà une quantité incroyable de
recherche qui nous montrent que les
individus psychologiquement sont
différents et ils sont différents
pas uniquement à cause de la culture
mais bien parce qu'ils sont différents
dès la naissance
évidemment il ya plein de gens on en
parlait un peu tout à l'heure quand tu
leur dis ça au niveau scandale ils vont
accuser de racisme ils vont accuser de
sexiste et je vais je vais sûrement m'en
prendre plein la gueule mais ces défis
sujet que je pense qu'ils sont vraiment
importants
d'abord des dons notamment par exemple
pour la médecine quoi si tu considères
que si tu considères que tous les
individus sont les mêmes alors tu peux
créer un médicament et le donner à tous
les individus et ce médicament il
conviendra à tous les individus
bon c'est pas ça qu'on observe par
exemple on observe que alors si c'est
déjà ça qu'on fait par exemple on s'est
rendu compte qu'il ya énormément de
médicaments pour traiter les maladies
mentales qui sont des médicaments qui
ont été créés pour les hommes
ils ont été créés en étudiant des hommes
ils ont été créés en par exemple les
doses recommandées pour ce médicament ça
va être une dose qui est adapté à la
masse d'un homme prénommé pas au poids
des femmes évidemment ça ça pose des
problèmes très importants mais si tu
postules qu'il ya que les différences
qui a pas de différences psychologiques
entre hommes et femmes
ben c'est pas un problème de faire ça tu
crées un médicament pour les hommes et
puis tu peut le donner aux femmes
ensuite puisque tout le monde est pareil
mais évidemment s'il existe des
différences entre le cerveau des hommes
et entre le cerveau des femmes et moi
c'est vraiment une grosse discrimination
de faire ça ce qui est marrant
d'ailleurs c'est que c'est souvent les
mêmes personnes qui se battent contre ça
donc les personnes qui sont pas
contentes que la recherche en médecine
soit biaisée en faveur des hommes ce
sont les mêmes personnes qui pensent
qu'il n'existe pas de différence
cognitive entre hommes et femmes mais je
sais pas si tu vois ce que je veux dire
quoi
en fait les idéologies ouais ouais je
pense que beaucoup de gens ont cette
envie de l'égalitarisme une motivation
l'égalitarisme et du coup ils vont
chercher lui l'égalitarisme
je pense que c'est une façon aussi de
justifier l'idéologie guitariste que de
dire bon ben on est tous égaux dès la
naissance
une tribu logiquement ouais en fait ce
n'est en fait c'est pour moi c'est
vraiment une erreur de raisonnement skip
ce qu'ils disent ce que je pense qu'il
se passe dans leur tête c'est que pour
que les gens soient égaux il faut qu'ils
soient tous les mêmes et ça pour moi
c'est vraiment une erreur de
raisonnement il ya pas biya pas besoin
que deux individus soit exactement les
mêmes pour qu'ils aient les mêmes droits
vraiment pas besoin de ça et d'ailleurs
c'est exactement ce qu'on fait pour le
racisme quand tu te bats contre le
racisme qu'est ce que tu fais tu dis pas
un noir et un blanc ils doivent avoir
les mêmes droits
parce qu'ils ont la même couleur de peau
tu vois ça n'a pas de sens un blanc et
un noir ils doivent avoir les mêmes
droits peu importe les différences de
couleur de peau qu'ils ont et c'est
exactement la même chose qu'il faut
faire pour les différences cognitive
il existe des différences cognitive
psychologique entre individus qui ont
des origines biologiques on le sait même
si même si on n'en parle pas beaucoup
dans les médias justement parce que
c'est politiquement incorrect on le sait
depuis déjà plusieurs années
il existe des différences mais ces
différences ne ne peuvent pas faire la
base de discrimination quoi
après le jouer l'hymne que
l'intelligence enfin sur une passe de
fonctions cognitives les intelligences
et un sujet encore plus sensible que la
couleur de pop parce que on attache
beaucoup de valeur tu es vivant c'est au
moins conscients que notre ans a
considéré qu'ils allaient être
intelligent c'est mieux
bah en fait j'ai réfléchi à ça parce que
c'est une idée que vous avez déjà évoqué
dans un axiome j'y réfléchis je pense
que dans une perspective utilitariste
pourquoi pas tu pourrais dire que
quelqu'un d'intelligent il aurait plus
de valeur en soi mais je pense que ce
que fait notre cerveau dans la vie dans
la vie de tous les jours c'est pas ça
par exemple imagine que tu es dans la
file de la boulangerie en train de faire
la queue et tu te fais doubler par
einstein
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que tu fais quoi est
ce que tu lui dis c'est ok t'es einstein
tu es très intelligente a le droit de me
doubler ou est ce que tu lui dis donc
retourne derrière moi tu achèteras pâte
et chocolatines avant moi en fait je
pense que dans la vie de tous les jours
ces différences cognitive on les prend
pas en compte ses doigts parce que
quelqu'un est super intelligent fin moi
en tout cas c'est pas parce que einstein
le doute dans la file de la boulangerie
que je vais le laisser faire quoi je
vais les engueuler copieusement et puis
je vais le renvoyer derrière edwards est
bien un autographe au pressage choisi
city situé sur la chocolatine oui et
inversement tu vois je me permettrai
jamais de doubler quelqu'un dans la file
parce que je sais que il
il est beaucoup plus con que moi tu vois
je me permettrai jamais de doubler un
géologue dans la file de la boulangerie
punchy et donc en fait je pense que même
cette idée selon laquelle s'il ya des
différences d'intelligence entre
individus ça pourrait justifier des
discriminations le jeu je sais pas je ne
pense pas que ce soit vraiment un bon
argument je suis d'accord après je pense
que le raisonnement que beaucoup de gens
c'est plus l'intelligence c'est bien de
soi et du coup dire que certaines
personnes sont plus intelligents ont des
facultés cognitives supérieures
dès la naissance fait qu' il n'y a pas
d'égalité mais c'est pas juste une
inégalité la sénilité quasiment de
valeur du coup ça ça pose plus problème
est dû par sa présence
ouais bah non je à ces genres dans un
petit quotité response qui ne font pas
enfin comme tu dit ce petit truc il
reste des raisonnements un peu plus
complexe mais de base en au point des
outils triste tout le monde sont comptés
et compter fin le bonheur du monde est
content et de même façon indépendamment
de leur intelligence
mais en pratique souvent on attribue à
certaines caractéristiques des valeurs
et je pense que typiquement
l'intelligence on attribue une valeur
très ce moment inconscientes une valeur
en soi à l'intelligence enfin tout comme
moi c'est un truc qu'on va beaucoup dis
pas ce que je suis je suis petit et j'ai
toujours été le plus petit de ma classe
et du coup beaucoup de gens nous
disaient porter vidéo fait exprès je me
la caméra tout en bas du contre projet
mais du coup un tel que beaucoup de gens
me disaient pour me remonter le moral
c'est-à-dire par des petits mais tu es
intelligent et comme si le fait d'être
intelligent compenser le la
caractéristique à dakar était négative
qu'il était être petit ouais je
comprends mais juste juste un jeu
trouble exemple très intéressant parce
que s'il dit ça ça veut dire que la
taille aussi par exemple la taille
physique c'est quelque chose qui a une
valeur c'est valoriser des plus grandes
tout comme s'est valorisé de plus
intelligent tu vois
et pourtant les gens acceptent très bien
que la taille physique et des
différences génétiques des différences
de taille qu'ils soient d'origine
génétique et ça pose pas vraiment de
problème pour moi c'est exactement la
même chose quand il va exister saute on
le sait déjà un peu la recherche des
buts un peu mais tu peux être sûr que
dans les années qui viennent on va
montrer que c'est certain un individu
certains individus qui portent certes un
allèle jen sont dé des chances plus
importantes en moyen d'être intelligent
tu peux être sûr que ça va être montré
il est la réaction qu'il faut avoir face
à ça pour moi c'est exactement la même
réaction qu'on a sur les différences de
taille entre individus c'est de dire bah
oui ce type qui est grand il a un peu
plus de chance que les petits il a
peut-être un peu plus de valeur mais
c'est pas pour ça que il a plus de droit
que quelqu'un d'autre n'est une réaction
que j'ai beaucoup vu du coût par rapport
à ma taille j'ai l'impression de faire
un complexe
je vois qu'on en discute mais du coup
c'est beaucoup de gens essaient de me
dire ah ben c'est pas la taille qui
compte hdz expression une des réactions
c'est justement essayer de d'enlever la
commutation de positive à la taille et
ça ça se fait dire au maintenant que je
suis adulte personnes temps en temps une
petite remarque sur la taille mais bon
personne ne va me faire chier sur la
taille va dire alors que sur
l'intelligence aller les gens vont
pouvoir souligné un petit peu atteint
intelligent avec un air un peu ça des
valeurs il me semble plus difficile
d'enlever la connotation positive
l'intelligence c'est ouais c'est
peut-être plus difficile mais entre je
pense que c'est quand même quelque chose
qu'on peut faire à mon avis on peut dire
par exemple on connaît tous des gens qui
sont très intelligents mais qui sont des
gros connard donc tu pourrais très bien
dire dans ce cas là ce n'est pas
l'intelligence qui compte aussi c'est
plus les qualités humaines
avec elle et relationnel etc je pense
qu'on peut faire le même raisonnement
dans le cadre de l'intelligence et par
extension de toutes les capacités
cognitives qui peut dire c'est pas ça
qui compte pour quasiment toutes les
capacités
maintenant si c'est une haleine qui
permet on arrive à avoir un allèle qui
qui permet de prédire que la personne
soit un connard qu'elle ait pas
confusion
bah c'est ça sera intéressant un
scientifiquement
ça risque d'être encore un sujet chaud
ouais il va y avoir il va y avoir
beaucoup dit qu'ils aimeraient beaucoup
de sujets chauds à l'avenir et j'espère
je vais essayer de les traiter des
traités ou bien en étant avec en étant
raisonnable mais j'espère que j'aurai du
soutien de la communauté de toute la
communauté vulgarisatrice la communauté
et éthique et c'est parce que les
médecins il ya une grosse communauté de
médecins nos factures sur internet donc
tu vois ils peuvent se serrer les coudes
et c'est les esthéticiens aussi une
grosse communauté
il est pour l'instant que j'ai vu très
peu de personnes aborder ces questions
épineuses des différences biologiques
entre individus pas bien entre hommes et
femmes entre individus de façon générale
et si c'est moi le premier qui met le
pied à dire match assez de bon courage
merci et je serai je t'ai soutiendrait
tu meures passe ici dit pas des grosses
conneries mais oui mais non mais en
prenant on en rigole mais en vrai andres
est pas drôle du tout il ya des
il ya des professeurs dans certaines
universités qui n'osent plus parler de
ces sujets là parce qu'ils savent très
bien qu'ils vont se faire lyncher soit
directement par leurs étudiants soient
plus tard sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est vraiment un gros problème que
c'est c'est vraiment un gros problème
l'emprise de l'idéologie surtout ses
résultats scientifiques
ouais du coup est ce que tu penses que
une réponse est non mais j'ai apprise
quand même ce que tu penses que tu dis
si c'est une question éthique qui se
pose que de s'autoriser à faire la
recherche dans ces domaines
ouais je pense que la question se pose
si je pense que la question se pose j'ai
deux donc comment dire ça je pense que
j'ai deux éléments de réponse à cette
question éthique pour moi il faut
étudier les différences d'origine
biologique entre les individus
pour deux raisons la première raison
c'est la raison classique que que la
science elle se contente de décrire le
monde la science elle n'a pas à se
prononcer sur ce qui doit être tu as et
le digitimes de yum le truc classique la
science elle dit ce qui est et elle ne
peut pas c'est pas qu'elle ne doit pas
dire ce qui doit être c'est qu'elle ne
peut pas dire ce qui doit être
et du coup les laisser bosser les
scientifiques dans leur coin ils font
ils font que décrire le monde après si
vous utiliser ses connaissances
scientifiques à mauvais escient c'est
votre problème
je pense que c'est un argument quand
même assez important parce que je parte
aurait très bien pu dire aux premiers
humains qui a découvert le feu aurait
très bien pu lui dire mais tu penses pas
que maîtriser le feu ça va avoir des
problèmes
il ya ce type il va pouvoir prendre une
torche est allé cramer sa femme et ses
petits commencent à suivre ce genre de
raisonnement que l'on peut plus
comprendre le monde c'est très difficile
de savoir où mettre la limite tu peux
appliquer ce raisonnement a quasiment
tout puisque quasiment tous quasiment
toute connaissance peut être dangereuse
quand elle est mise dans des mauvaises
mains
la réplique classique cette question
c'est le far nucléaire est-ce que ça
posait des problèmes éthiques de fer à
rechercher sur les rails s'était produit
ouais je me suis posé la question je me
demande s'il n'y a pas à une différence
entre le nucléaire et ce dont on parle
la psychologie évolutionnaire parce que
le nucléaire c'est des scientifiques qui
agissent sur le monde déjà qui
transforment le monde tant d'éclat
psychologie évolutionnaire c'est juste
de la description du monde cordes et
qu'on n'essaie pas de transformer
l'humain on le décrit tel qu'il est je
me demande si on peut pas faire cette
distinction là maintenant peut-être
qu'un philosophe il me dirait que la
distinction elle tient pas vraiment
parce que parce que dans un sens la
bombe nucléaire c'est aussi de la
description en quoi tu dis que tu décris
ce qui se passe quand tu fais certaines
opérations sur des atomes et c est donc
je ne sais pas bien quoi répondent
j'aurais tendance à dire que oui il faut
laisser les scientifiques étudier ces
sujets mais en tout cas c'est un sujet
qui est débattue il ya quelques années
il y avait eu un numéro de saïan selon
le journal science qui avait traité de
ce problème là précisément où il
exposait les arguments des uns et des
autres aimer mon deuxième argument c'est
l'argument dont on a discuté juste avant
c'est que si tu situe ni l'existence de
différences entre individus
tu peut pas remédier à ces différences
donc par exemple le cas de la médecine
site unique ait des différences entre
les hommes et les femmes
eh ben ça sert à rien de créer des de
créer des médicaments qu'ils soient
spécifiques aux femmes
c'est ça c'est vrai dans le monde de la
médecine c'est vrai dans le monde de
l'éducation
si tu penses que tous les individus ne
naissent égaux d'un point de vue
biologique à la naissance
alors si tu veux donner inégal
considération à chaque individu tout ce
que tu as à faire c'est donner la même
éducation à tout le monde mais il
imagine la catastrophe que tu es en
train de créer si jamais tous les
individus sont pas égaux ce que tu es en
train de faire c'est que tu va renforcer
les inégalités en quelque sorte les ceux
qui sont ceux qui sont les plus
avantagés naturellement bon ils vont
être satisfaits l'éducation tu leur
donnes et ceux qui sont moins
d'avantagés ils vont complètement
décrochés et donc tu va renforcer les
inégalités c'est ça c'est ça c'est pour
moi c'est la raison principale pour
laquelle il faut étudier les différences
c'est que si t'as pas conscience qu'il
ya des différences d'origine biologique
tu peux pas y remédier ce serait salle
le point principal mais ça chauffe ça
c'est qu'on est devant le dans mon livre
je donne l'exemple de deux des bus dans
les bus déplacement plupart des bus dans
le monde il ya des places qui sont
priorité est laissée aux personnes
enceintes âgées et handicapées ouais et
sony réfléchit ça ça revient en fait
le bus est en train d'en fait
d'encourager ou la ratp est en train
d'encourager les utilisateurs du bus à
faire un jugement de faciès sur les
autres à partir leur apparence physique
ouais et d'utiliser ça pour ensuite
modifié leur comportement vis-à-vis de
ces personnes ouais ouais ouais je pense
que c'est la même chose quoi c'est juste
reconnaître que les gens sont différents
et du coup il faut un traitement adapté
pour ces différences en particulier un
traitement égalitariste dans ce cas
semble moins cheap en tout cas moins
intuitive mans que considérer les
différences entre les différentes
personnes et adopter une solution une
certaine manière comprendre les
différences entre différentes personnes
permet de mieux adopter les solutions
est de venir en aide plus rapidement
ceux qui ont plus besoin dead d'adapter
les exactement ce que ce que montrent
les études sur sur ces sujets là c'est
que les gens ils sont pas opposés aux
inégalités en soit les gens ils sont
opposés aux inégalités qui sont injustes
c'est vraiment deux choses différentes
par exemple les gens ils sont ok quand
tu fais des sondages c'est pas moi qui
le dit c'est des sondages trouve normal
de payer plus un médecin que le caissier
à un supermarché c'est une inégalité en
fait d'un salaire plus important à l'un
qu'à l'autre
mais c'est une inégalité que les gens ne
trouvent pas injuste pour différentes
raisons qu'un médecin a l'air d'apporter
plus d'utilité à société etc
mais cette idée selon laquelle
d'inégalités ce serait mal en soi c'est
quelque chose qui est
fortement remis en question quand on
commence à y réfléchir
et quand on commence à faire des des
sondages placent le mal c'est
l'injustice et l'inégalité injuste mais
l'inégalité en tant que tel a priori les
gens trouvent ça acceptable a été c'est
du coup c'est que l'injustice et alors
je vais faire
j'ai pas envie de t'en parler parce que
je suis en train de faire une série
ma prochaine série sur home of abuse va
parler de la morale je fais un espèce de
petit teaser d'ailleurs je devrais être
en train de travailler sur cette série
en ce moment même où plutôt que de
répondre à cette interview tu es en
train de retarder et met donc j'avais
parlé de tout ça en détail et je vais
parler d'une explication de la morale
qui est plus poussé que j'ai encore
jamais vulgariser et je pense qu'elle te
plaire c'est une explication
relativement simple mais qui permet
d'expliquer pas mal de trucs que ce
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure que c'est
une explication qui donne du sens à
beaucoup de données et et cette
explication elle te dira ce qu'est la
justice selon moi enfin selon selon la
recherche que j'ai fait pendant matin
soir d'un récit bien assez de voir ça du
coup au teaser sinon pour en revenir aux
réalités des questions sur qu'est ce
qu'on pourrait faire de mieux est ce que
tu penses que la relecture de scripts
devrait être plus généralisée au café
des sciences
moi je pense que oui dans l'idéal elle
devrait être plus généralisé mais ça
demande tellement de temps quoi c'est ça
c'est ça le truc que je peux pas on peut
pas fou je peux pas forcer les membres à
relire les scripts alors je vais en
profiter pour faire la pub de groupes de
facebook de discussion qu'on a on a des
groupes qui servent justement à relire
les scripts des groupes qui sont
thématiques donc il ya un groupe pour la
physique un groupe pour la biologie si
vous allez sur le site du café des
sciences je pense que vous aurez le lien
pourra peut-être mettre le lien dans la
description de la vidéo et je me
rappelle jamais s'il est si les groupes
sont ouverts au grand public mais je
crois que oui
donc si jamais vous qui nous écoute et
vous avez des compétences dans un
certain domaine
allez vous inscrire sur un de ces
groupes et de temps en temps il ya des
gens pas que des gens du café des
sciences d'ailleurs qui postent un
script et on peut relire ce script en
quoi si vous avez des compétences à
allez n'hésitez pas à aller sur un de
ces groupes
et si vous avez des scripts à faire
relire n'hésitez pas non plus à l'est
sur ces groupes aimeraient pour répondre
à ta question
ouais je pense qu'on en a jamais
vraiment trop de relecture mais voilà ça
c'est du travail
tous ces gens au café des sciences il
travaille déjà beaucoup de façon
bénévole notamment
donc je jouais mal comment on pourrait
les forcer à relire plus de scripteurs
d'aller voir sur si l'univers m'était
conté qui est le groupe facebook pour la
relecture de scripts en maths physique
des trucs un peu comme ça c'est un
groupe fermé et j'ai même si vous
demandez à rejoindre le groupe
ouais je crois que ça marche comme ça
vous vous présenter rapidement
juste histoire dont on fait un tri
minimum et puis et puis vous serez
accepté et puis sinon l'autre truc
peut-être je peux tu me diras s'excusant
si c'est un truc à améliorer c'est
peut-être la proximité avec la recherche
voyez comme pas mal de deux gladiateurs
qui ont été dans la recherche ou qui
sont de recherche
mais ce que je pense qu'il faudrait
quand même nous vers plus de liens avec
le monde de la recherche
et est ce que c'est possible parce que
c'est ouais je rêve je réfléchis j'ai le
droit
ce groupe de réflexion j'ai un pauvre
cerveau de biologistes psychologue
m'excuseras quasi géologue
ouais c'est ça presque géologue et une
époque c'est pour te dire que je regarde
vraiment avec la pseudo séance new way
moi je pense que c'est jamais nous c'est
jamais mal d'être prof proche des
chercheurs je vois pas en quoi cela
pourrait être mal et c'est d'ailleurs un
truc que je fais sur mot fabulous je
présente le travail des chercheurs à la
fin de chacune de mes vidéos parce que
j'ai pas envie que ce soit juste des
gens qui ont relu le script je veux
vraiment présenter le travail de ces
gens qui font tout le boulot quoi qui
consacrent leur vie à étudier
un gène ou une protéine un mécanisme
mental et c'est le youtuber qui prend
tout le tout la popularité mais ça
devrait être les chercheurs qui sont sur
le devant de la scène
et donc je vois pas ce qui pourrait
arriver mal de faire plus de
collaboration avec des chercheurs si ce
n'est que ça retarde un peu l'écriture
des scripts ça c'est un truc dont
discutent et gilles d'ailleurs c'est que
quand tu dois attendre des retours sur
un script satar est un peu dans ton élan
c'est peut-être ça le point négatif est
ce que c'est possible de le faire il ya
le problème dont on discutait tout à
l'heure que pour les gens qui sont pas
dans le milieu
c'est dur de savoir qui contacter et et
peut-être même une fois que tu contactes
les gens alors moi de mon expérience
quand tu contactes d'un chercheur et que
tu lui demande son avis ou que tu lui
dis j'ai lu votre recherche
je trouve ça génial et c'est ce que vous
pouvez répondre à une ou deux questions
en général l'accueil est très favorable
justement entre autres parce que les
chercheurs
ils souffrent vraiment d'un manque de
reconnaissance du public si tu leur dis
que tu t'intéresses à leur travail ils
seront très contents et voudront bien
télé maintenant c'est possible aussi que
certains chercheurs qui se demande à
quoi ça va leur servir c'est la
vulgarisation là ces types sur youtube
ce que c'est pas juste du temps perdu
ce qui est vrai en quelque sorte moi
j'adorerais que les chercheurs
quand il postule à un poste il soit
évalué non pas sur leurs travaux
scientifiques sur le nombre d'articles
qu'ils ont publiées mais sur la
vulgarisation qu'ils ont fait de leurs
travaux qu'on leur demande
voilà quand ils postulent qu'est ce que
vous avez fait pour promouvoir vos
travaux dans le grand public mais pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas donc dans
un sens c'est compréhensible qu'un
chercheur et du mal à vouloir lire un
script je pense que ça serait chercheurs
de vulgariser leurs recherches
ouais je je ne dis pas que c'est facile
je ne dis pas qu'ils sont tous bon en
fait je pense même qu'on a beaucoup qui
sont très mauvais pour faire ça j'ai eu
les couilles les cours que j'ai eu à le
nsc tu es tout temps des cours par les
chercheurs et j'ai eu certes un cours
qui étaient très bons mais certains
cours qui était catastrophique
tout simplement parce que ces décomptes
des compétences un peu différente que
pour être chercheur et pour être
enseignant vulgarisateur sait pas
exactement la même chose donc je dis pas
que tous les chercheurs serait bon pour
faire ça mais mais pour moi ça ils
devraient essayer au moins quoi c'est ça
le truc on devrait tous ont essayé
oui parce que c'est une autre réflexion
je me ferais plutôt c1 ça serait bien
d'avoir des gens qui sont un peu plus
spécialisés pour la vulgarisation du
travail des chercheurs mais du coup ça
serait des personnes qui devraient être
vraiment à l'aise avec la recherche de
ces chercheurs étaient vraiment des gens
en gros tu critiques qui ont fait de la
recherche même dans le domaine également
et qui sont également très bons pour
faire les bulgares isation pressé c'est
par un poste this way je comprends que
je comprends tu veux créer un poste dans
les équipes de recherche par team ico et
si je pense que mon avis c'est encore
mieux
le seul problème que je vois c'est si
jamais
ces gens ils ont quand même du mal à
vraiment comprendre le sujet de
recherche si des fois le sujet est
tellement tellement précis que quelqu'un
qui n'est pas dedans il ne pourra il
pourra pas bien l'appréhender où il
pourra pas faire une bonne synthèse par
exemple mais sinon ouais ce serait
encore mieux ce serait encore mieux
est-ce que je pense que la compétence de
vulgarisation alors ok a elle-même du
travail s'entraîner à vulgariser pour
bien d'arriver en tout cas de mon
expérience et du coup avoir quelqu'un
qui est vraiment cette expertise puisque
son expertise à développer ouais non non
si c'est faire c'est un métier j'aurai
quand même tendance à penser qu' il ya
une fois de plus des bases biologiques à
ce truc
certaines personnes qui sont qu'ils
soient plus doués naturellement entre
guillemets pour la vulgarisation que
d'autres mais sinon c'est vrai qu'on
peut énormément s'améliorer en le
travaillant en répétant et c'est donc
sinon ce sera elle ce serait génial qui
est d'aider des vulgarisateurs dans
chaque équipe scientifique mais à défaut
de ça je pense ce serait déjà pas mal
que les chercheurs ils s'y mettent un
peu et qui
et que parraine par exemple que quand il
quand ils font une demande de
financement c'est-à-dire quand ils
soumettent un projet pour recevoir des
sous il y est systématiquement dans ses
appels à projets une partie
vulgarisation qu' ils soient évalués sur
la façon dont ils vont dont ils vont
transmettre leurs connaissances
transmettre ce qu'ils ont découvert voir
voire même tu vois il peuvent juste
demandé un budget est ensuite allé payer
un vulgarisateur schiro ce qui
rejoindrait l'idée que tu proposes si
jeune si jamais ils n'ont pas envie de
vulgariser le même mais comme comme
souvent c'est les chercheurs qui
reçoivent les sous et les chercheurs qui
sont évalués c'est important que mon
avis est important que les chercheurs
soient vraiment eu même inscrit dans
cette démarche de vulgarisation quoi que
ce soit pas mais qu'il faudrait en amont
dégâts que ça fasse partie des objectifs
qu'on leur assigne et que nous annonçons
aujourd'hui recrutement vulgarisation
ouais je ne sais pas c'est pas c'est pas
moi qui sort cette idée c'est une idée
que j'ai lu ou entendu je sais pas où et
ça fait ça fait des années qu'elles
flottent jeu en fait j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi ça va toujours pas
été implémenté quoi dit les types qui
filent les demandes de file de
financement lille pendant les types qui
filent les financements ils ont un
pouvoir énorme ici par exemple aux états
unis te dis si tu cites est un chercheur
si tu travailles avec de l'argent public
tu dois au final à vendre et recherche
publique
je vois pas pourquoi on ne pourrait pas
avoir la même chose pour la
vulgarisation si tu fais de la recherche
avec de l'argent public et mathieu doit
aussi faire vulgariser un peu de cette
recherche avec ce même argent
j'ai pas ça me paraît pas dur mais à ma
connaissance c'est toujours pas
implémenté je dis peut-être une bêtise
je j'ai juste fait une thèse donc j'ai
jamais vraiment une et fourré dans les
demandes de financement mais je sais pas
je sais pas si tu as entendu parler de
ça tout si ça existe déjà un petit peu
dans certaines dans certains coins dans
certaines équipes
j'ai déjà entendu parler de l' inverse
d'une personne qui avait fait une
demande en pleine de bon sens et déjà
fait engueuler pour avoir fait de la
vulgarisation
parce que ça me ça prenait du temps pour
rien c'est sa voix aux caisses comme ça
je pense qu'il est même un air de vous
vous prenez pour qui pour faire de la
vulgarisation
je sais que ouais du genre le type il va
être star sur youtube ou un truc du
genre conway
alors que la recherche si sérieux je
pense qu'il ya un petit peu une image un
peu comme ça c'est pas du tout le cas le
pf alors c'est des gens si c'est des
gens de le pfl aussi à mes patrons à
l'opéra qui écoute dans lequel elle
c'est génial tout va très bien pour moi
c'est non de façon plus générale comment
tu t'es fort mais comment tu vas
les questions étaient sources
d'information alors je ma forme
alors pour ce qui est du patiente ific
ça m'a fait ça m'a fait marrer quand on
a posé la question à christophe michel
et je crois que tu as un peu la même
façon de faire que lui c'est à dire
qu'il dit qui suit très peu l'actualité
est en fait moi je partage avec vous le
fait que je trouve l'actualité très très
chiante vraiment pas intéressante que
c'est du court terme etc
mais je la suis quand même que c'est à
dire que quasiment tous les jours je
vais faire un tour sur lemonde.fr ou
n'importe quelle cible de
d'actu un peu généraliste et je me tiens
informé j'ai cette idée que si tu te
tiens pas informé de l'actualité
ça peut être dangereux dans un sens je
ne sais pas si c'est une idée vraiment
justifiée ou pas dans le sens où je sais
pas on peut y avoir une loi qui passe
n'était pas au courant qui va changer ta
vie
j'ai découvert que l'article et 13
étaient pressés par accident ben voilà
par exemple je pensais un peu pour ça
que je suis l'actualité mais sinon je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec le
constat de pas mal de de vulgarisateur
qui de dire que on manque vraiment trop
de recul sur voilà surtout ce qui est
traité dans les médias il ya plein de
trucs est pas intéressant je parle même
pas des faits divers je parle même des
sections scientifiques des des médias
c'est ce que je dis dans ma dernière
vidéo sur les niveaux de preuve sur homo
fabius c'est que les médias ils
subissent la dictature de l'actualité
ils veulent tout le temps présenter de
l'information fraîche qui vient de
sortir et du coup ils ont aucun recul
sur les informations qui présentait et
voilà c'est vraiment le dommage est
typiquement dans mon champ dans la
psychologie évolutionnaire dès qu'il va
y avoir une étude qui montre que une
différence entre hommes et femmes et
culturel tu vois un truc du genre
cette étude va être reprise par tous
elle va complètement ignoré les dizaines
d'années d'études qu'on a fait sur le
sujet des études chez les animaux qui
montre que les mêmes comportements que
les animaux non humains ont les mêmes
comportements
enfin c'est vraiment a vraiment de quoi
t'énerver en suivant l'actualité mais je
le fais quand même un petit peu il pour
ce qui est du côté scientifique
je fais un petit peu de vidéos youtube
mais je pense que j'en fais beaucoup
moins que la plupart d'entre vous que la
plupart que toi par exemple j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya des gens ils
passent leur vie sur youtube quoi ces
intrigues et moi je ne sais pas rien que
pour faire une de mes vidéos tu vois ça
peut me prendre facilement de deux
semaines rien que pour rechercher la
littérature
enfin de lire toute la littérature etc
ça me prend deux semaines à temps plein
c'est vraiment un boulot énorme et du
coup quand j'ai fait ça j'ai déjà appris
beaucoup de choses et j'ai plus beaucoup
de temps pour apprendre d'autres choses
donc je donc dont je m'informe par les
publications principalement par les les
livres de mai les livres de
vulgarisation les textes books une bonne
j'aime beaucoup le texte book in text
books et des bouquins qui sont écrits
pour les licences souvent et qui résume
bien qui résume bien un champ et voilà
un petit peu de vidéos de blogs etc
mais c'est vraiment plus au compte
gouttes je me demande si je ne devrais
pas me forcer un petit peu me dire je me
bloque une demi journée par semaine pour
faire que du visionnage de vidéos
youtube
je devrais peut-être faire ça parce qu'à
chaque fois je le fais je trouve des
trucs géniaux quoi et six par jour un
fixe pour toi d'aller sur youtube
aucun nom isabeau non non non non je
vais plus souvent sur l'equipe.fr que
sur youtube.com à tepito l'équipe
ouais un petit peu aussi je ne veux pas
croire que je fais que procrastiner sur
l'équipe mais en fait c'est aussi c'est
aussi dieu c'est aussi dû au fait que
comme mon boulot c'est déjà de faire de
la recherche et déjà de faire la
vulgarisation g20 je suis vraiment
fatigué cognitivement à la fin de la
journée au milieu de la journée
et du coup quand j'ai cinq dix minutes
pour moi je vais pas en plus encore à
les faire travailler mes neurones tu
vois je vais aller je vais aller
regarder une vidéo de starcraft ou à les
regarder le dernier coup franc de messi
ou un truc comme ça quoi et aussi cet
aspect là que
un moment je sature cognitivement et du
coup quand j'ai du temps libre je le
passe à faire autre chose que regarder
de la vulgarisation
donc s'ils pouvaient revenir en arrière
qu'est ce que tu dirais témoin du passé
des choses que tu aimerais de lui dire
ouais ça c'est une question pas choisi
je lui dirai continues comme ça tu fais
du bon boulot
non j'étais au ministre de vulgarisation
ouais c'est ça tu as déjà évité la
géologie c'est déjà pas mal
je en fait je pense que bizarrement je
vais dire est de lire plus plus plus tôt
en fait je pense que si j'avais lu plus
de vulgarisation quand j'étais plus
jeune
ça m'aurait beaucoup aidé dans mes
études j'aurais été beaucoup moins
ignorants beaucoup plus rapidement et
quand j'étais jeune en fait quand
j'étais au lycée et au collège au lycée
je le disais très peu de tous ces
bouquins j'avais pas de bouquins de
sciences à la maison paco qu'un bouquin
de vulgarisation j'habitais dans un
troupeau mais j'habite toujours dans un
trou paumé d'ailleurs qui est le lot qui
est un peu un désert culturel que c'est
vraiment la cambrousse à une
bibliothèque tout petit donc c'était
c'est très dur de mettre la main sur des
ouvrages
évidemment il ya l'internet internet
qu'on connaît n'existait pas à l'époque
mais tout ça ça fait que j'ai pas
beaucoup lui il que j'ai découverte des
idées révolutionnaires très très tard
par exemple le gène égoïste de dawkins
je les lui j'avais 22 23 ans c'est
vraiment pour moi je trouve faisait
hyper tard alors que maintenant je le
place pour moi c'est là c'est la plus
belle idée que j'ai jamais rencontré
dans toute ma carrière de chercheur tout
je suis sûr que c'est le cas dans plein
d'autres domaines par exemple quand je
tombe sur un livre ligue bostrom gelé
découvert avec toi et monsieur fille je
trouve que c'est cet art que j'aurais dû
j'aurais dû connaître toutes ces idées
avant je suis sûr que ça m'aurait aidé
même dans ma recherche ça m'aurait aidé
à faire des connexions entre différents
domaines à réutiliser des idées parce
que c'est aussi beaucoup ça la recherche
des ces deux de réutiliser des idées
voir comment des idées d'un certain
domaine elles peuvent être exportées
dans un autre domaine
je pense que j'aurais été beaucoup moins
con si je vais commencer à lire des
livres plutôt mais n'a presque pas
facile d'être son appareil je pense que
ces livres le char dawkins je pense que
j'ai découvert un vin un peu comme toi
en quelques années et l'hippodrome j'ai
découvert il ya deux ans trois ans de
bonnes raisons tout ça était très récent
également ssp juste pas facilement être
cours de danse j'aimerais a eu le ouais
mais c'est le côté bénéfique de youtube
c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai voulu
c'était une des raisons pour lesquelles
je voulais arrêter la recherche après le
doctorat c'est que on est vraiment trop
spécialisées trop dans notre bulle que
tu voulais en particulier faire le tour
d'horizon sur des sciences politiques
virgin que je soupçonne ouais c'est ça
je voulais comprendre le comportement
humain dans toutes ses dimensions quoi
je voulais faire des
des des neurosciences de l'anthropologie
de l'économie de la psychologie des
sciences sociales fin je voulais je
voulais vraiment avoir une approche
pluridisciplinaire de de cette étude du
comportement humain et puis si possible
me dégager du temps tout ce qui est
physique aussi toi toi tu connais un peu
je pense tout ce qui est physique mais
moi tout ce qui est des que david loix
prix fait une vidéo de physique sur
l'univers ou d'être comme ça c'est comme
si je partais de zéro j'ai vraiment
n'est qu'il est vraiment quasiment
aucune connaissance là dessus il ya
plein de jeux de de gens à qui je parle
tous les jours sur twitter des gens qui
sont pas du domaine scientifique qui ont
une culture générale scientifique
beaucoup plus grande que la vienne que
ça c'est vraiment certain quoi ne jouez
jamais au trivial pursuit avec moi ou
enfin je ne sais pas quel jeu de culture
générale même jeu de culture générale
scientifique je suis vraiment une grosse
merde vous mettez pas dans mon équipe
mais voilà j'essaie d'y remédier moi
j'essaie de travailler là dessus
ouais j'ai appris plein de choses qui
prennent vraiment énormément de temps à
coup de théorie quantique eu des chiens
trick
je crois que j'ai essayé de dire à son
septième livre que j'essaie de lire et
je suis pour rien c'est pas du tout
vulgariser pas rien webb à l'eva jolie
des techs bouquet qui sont déjà des
diversions bien bien présenter des
articles de recherche et voilà c'est pas
facile c'est pas facile j'étais
j'attends celui de l'été david e qu'est
ce qu'il fait ce david alors litres
aînés traînent sérieux mais pas un peu
bougé pour les sciences quelques clics
et le truc le plus fou que tu as appris
au cours d'hier la des deux dernières
années dans ton domaine où ailleurs deux
dernières années ligue bostrom j'ai
beaucoup aimé l'appartement de la
simulation
ça je trouve c'est un truc voilà assez
élégant maintenant je sais pas si je
dirais que c'est le plus fou ça fait
partie des plus fous tresserre très
certainement je dirais bien le fait qu'
il ya encore pas si longtemps à 50 mille
ans on pouvait trouver à la surface de
la terre
cinq espèces humaines différents que ça
c'est un truc
bon c'est un truc que j'ai appris
récemment en fait parce que j'ai pas
j'ai pas vraiment je leur dis ô combien
de temps cinquante mille ans cinquante
mille aux cinq espèces différentes
ouais et en particulier pour être avec
avait sapiens t'avais néandertal t'avais
l'homme de florès t'avais denisot va et
et en particulier si tu avais la chance
d'être un homme qui se trouvait à peu
près à la jonction entre l'europe et
l'asie
tu as tord et une probabilité vraiment
non négligeable de vraiment rencontrer
dans la vie de tous les jours une espèce
humaine différente et 50 me lancer
vraiment rien du tout cas c'est un truc
de fou coop comme quand je me suis rendu
compte de ça on est né en fait on est né
nous nous sommes aussi bien aujourd'hui
on est né juste après cette période où
il y avait plusieurs espèces humaines
qui coexistaient en même temps sur terre
et voilà je trouve ça formidable de me
dire que on a raté sa de peu
l'incroyable chance de le rencontrer
voilà en sortant de chez soi un humain
d'une autre et vous quand tu dis espèces
différentes à dire qu'ils pouvaient pas
se reproduire entre elles bah c'est si
elle pouvait pas ce qu'on sait par
exemple que néandertal et sapiens ils
ont ils ont échangé des gènes on a du
génome de néandertal dans notre génome
mais c'est des espèces ou sans ce moi
j'imagine que des espèces au sens des
critères de morphologie qui sont les
critères habituels de crâne de bp dit c
est là pour le coup il y aura des
différences biologiques
voilà pour les coûts ouais il y aura des
différences importantes là le cas des
discriminations il ya cinquante mille
ans je peux plus dire que ça devait être
chaud quoi sérieux qu'est ce que tu fais
quand je rencontre quelqu'un
d'une autre espèce est ce qu'ils avaient
ce qu'ils avaient tous un sens moral ça
c'est parce que moi je postule que le
sens moral c'est c'est commun c'est
universel donc chaque représentant de
l'espèce une main humaine il possède un
sens moral après je suis conscient que
la variabilité je suis conscient qu'on
est pas moral en permanence c'est pas ça
que je suis en train en train de dire je
suis juste en train de dire qu'on a des
que on a un sens moral universel qui a
évolué parce que c'était une adaptation
c'est à dire qu'il a évolué parce que il
est venu résoudre le sens moral a été
sélectionnée parce qu'il est venu
résoudre un problème de survie ou de
reproductions que nos ancêtres en vie
dans le passé et la question de savoir
est ce que ces autres espèces humaines
elle avait le même sens moral j'en sais
rien je pense que c'est très lié à la
coopération en fait si c'était des
espèces qu'ils coopéraient énormément
c'est possible qu'elle ait également eu
un sens moral ou quelque chose qui
ressemblait à notre propre sens moral de
l'espèce humaine ni du sim
une histoire de facultés cognitives mais
si c'est vraiment nécessaire vous êtes
capable de réfléchir à un peu une
philosophie l'esprit c'est de savoir une
théorie des sprinteurs
ce qui se passe dans la tête de l'autre
voilà ouais ouais ouais ouais il ya
plein de il ya plein d'autres
ingrédients qui sont nécessaires en
effet mais ouais mais il ya certaines
espèces animales on pense qu'elles ont
également une théorie de l'esprit
même si c'est une théorie minimaliste et
pourtant pour l'instant on pense qu'on
est la seule espèce animale à avoir un
sens moral comme je le dis dans ma vidéo
même si c'est pas sûr à 100% donc des
espèces animales qui ont des capacités
cognitives très développés il y en a des
espèces animales qui ont un sens moral
c'est beaucoup moins sûr ouais
après ouais après tu vois le fait
qu'aujourd'hui on moralise en fait
aujourd'hui on me réalise beaucoup les
animaux les animaux ils font partie de
ce qu'on appelle notre cercle morale
c'est à dire que on trouve ça pas normal
de de frapper un chat on ne sait pas
quoi donc c'est très possible que à
l'époque où croiser toutes ces espèces
humaines on trouvait pas cependant pas
ça normal non plus de de tuer un enfant
même d'une autre espèce quoi
comment est ce que tu vois le futur ces
inconnus de l'huma d'humanité à kaka
quels termes qui m'a dit cinq ans de 50
ans
[Musique]
et de façon générale dans cinq ans je
pense qu'il sera pas beaucoup changé par
rapport à aujourd'hui je pense que dans
cinq ans on commencera toujours à voir
mais on commencera tout juste à voir les
transformations dont tu parles les
intelligences artificielles les voitures
autonomes
à mon avis c'est vrai que ça commence à
démarrer vraiment dans quelques années
dans à plus long terme
j'ai pas c'est dur en fait tu poses la
question climatique non bon pour moi si
je réfléchis à long terme en fait le
premier truc qui me vient à l'esprit
c'est ce à quoi s'est où on sera du
point de vue du climat etc
et je pense moi je suis assez je suis
assez pessimiste alors c'est vraiment un
pistolet sur la tempe j'ai vraiment pas
de vision forte là dessus mais je suis
je suis assez pessimiste le pense qu'il
va falloir que j'en aie dans le mur et
que l'on raconte les premières
catastrophe naturelle pour commencer
vraiment à ce que les choses bougent et
après je pense pas que l'espèce humaine
va disparaître par exemple quel qu'il y
ait des populations entières qui soit
décimée
peut-être mais je pense qu'on arrivera
toujours à s'adapter
d'une façon ou d'une autre je pense que
le changement climatique est le plus
gros problème pour le futur par rapport
aux ja c'est ce à quoi d'autre chose
ouais pas forcément le changement qui ne
va pas que le changement climatique mais
l'épuisement des ressources en
particulier
tu voi e j'ai découvert avec une vidéo
de rodolphe la leur et veilleur qu'il y
avait des gros problèmes sur le
phosphate par exemple d'extraction du
phosphate qui nous sert qui est la base
de toute notre agriculture et que ça
allait s'épuise et bientôt je veux dire
il m'a dit le dr fois vraiment qu'il y
ait d'autres gisements qui ont été tous
les cas qu'il aurait il faillit qu'il
faudrait faire entre une mise à jour de
cette vidéo bulles c'est pas vraiment ça
salut c'était une fête news moi tu fais
bien désabonner immédiatement tue à le
dire et ducati
ouais mais bon bref on a gagné quelques
années de répit et si c'est pas le
phosphate ce sera autre chose donc
donc voilà on a vraiment une société qui
est basée sur certains principes et sur
certaines façons de consommer ouais je
dirais que c'est ça qui m'inquiète le
plus ce qui alors il ya des signes à
cette question de est-ce qu'on va
réussir à changer
c'est une question vraiment assez
importante pour moi est une question sur
laquelle les psychologues devraient
avoir leur mot à dire parce que à mon
avis si on résoudre cette question du
changement climatique les solutions pour
moi ce sont pas technologiques elles
seront peut-être en partie technologique
on va créer de la viande de synthèse etc
mais ça va passer avant tout par des
comportements et évidemment ce qui
étudie les comportements c'est entre
autres les psychologues et les
sociologues etc
donc nous chercheurs on va avoir un rôle
à jouer dans dans cette transition
climatique à voir comment on peut
arriver à aider les gens à changer de
comportement
c'était le sens de ma vidéo nadj il ya
une grosse question qui est vraiment
importante pour moi et j'ai je vais
faire une vidéo là dessus je pense et
mais j'ai pas ce que je pense qu'il ya
des données mais je les connais pas les
donner c'est à quel point on peut lutter
contre notre psychologie évolué c'est à
dire que on a notre psychologie elle est
faite de tout un tas d'intuition et
d'intuition qui sont souvent un produit
de façon automatique rapide inconsciente
enfin toi tu connais un peu le sujet
parce que tu as lu kahneman system un
système de et c'est jonathan wright
aussi ils en parlent ils
nathan drake il utilise la métaphore de
l'éléphant qui a un conducteur dit que
notre cerveau c'est un c'est un éléphant
il fait des trucs dans son coin il fait
plein de truc dans son coin et par
dessus on a un petit conducteur qui
essaie de donner du sens à ce que fait
les francos mai
le gros de ce que fait le cerveau ça se
fait de façon inconsciente dans un
éléphant est toute la question et c'est
à quel point le conducteur il peut
s'opposer à la volonté de l'éléphant
c'est à quel point notre raisonnement
rationnel
notre raisonnement réflexif il peut
s'opposer à hanovre à nos instincts quoi
aux intuitions que l'on a
par exemple j'ai pas l'instinct de
consommer toujours plus à quel point on
va être capable rationnellement de se
priver
l'instinct de jeu c'est pas le lag il
est question de vous poser avec
l'utilitarisme c'est exactement ça pour
moi aussi l'utilitarisme c'est quelque
chose qui n'est pas intuitif pour
beaucoup de gens parce que par exemple
tu acceptes de sacrifier une personne
pour en sauver 5
il ya plein de gens qui s'opposent à ça
la question va être est ce que c'est
quand même justifier de le faire dans
certains cas est ce que on va réussir à
s'opposer à notre psychologie évolué et
qui nous dit que ce n'est pas intuitif
de de sacrifier une personne même si
c'est pour en sauver 5 voilà est-ce que
est-ce qu'on va réussir
est ce que c'est possible et c'est ce
qu'il est ce qu'il faut le faire ça
c'est des questions ouvertes je pense
qu'il ya des gens qui sont intéressés à
ça mais il faut que je fasse une vidéo
là dessus je sais pas si tu as un avis
là dessus parce que je pense que c'est
vraiment une question fascinante et
urgente et ses rêves aussi un petit peu
psychologue
parce que calculé par rapport à ça mais
moi je pense que c'est vraiment un truc
essayer de développer un peu plus au
moins la prise de conscience que
on a ce système que qui s'est éléphants
et ouais mais ça ça dans les dents chez
les chercheurs c'est s'est répandue
c'est vraiment une connaissance répandue
ce qui est moins répandue enfin ce qui
est moins sûr c'est à quel point on peut
maîtriser cet éléphant peut-être le
grand public lui il en a moins il en a -
connaissance de cette différence
je vais en parler dans ma série sur la
morale par exemple est-ce que tu trouve
qu'elle est ce que tu penses que les
psychologues résonne dans son bras manga
face à au quotidien est-ce qu'ils
appliquent en gros leur recherche à eux
mêmes en dehors du cadre
non non non non je ne pense pas je pense
que le psychologue ils sont tout autant
que les autres sujets aux billets de
raisonnement qu'on fait ça tous les
jours
en fait on lit plein de trucs sur les
biens de raisonnement et dès qu'on ferme
notre ordinateur vous dès qu on ferme
notre bouquin on retourne on retourne
dans nos billets traditionnelle et pour
moi c'est pas très grave en fait il ya
des gens qui ont développé la théorie
argumentative du raisonnement dont je te
parlais tout à l'heure qui disent c'est
vrai qu'on a plein de billets de
raisonnement mais c'est pas grave parce
que quand on est plusieurs à débattre au
final le fait que chacun tire dans sa
propre direction chacun soit biaisée au
final ça fait que collectivement on va
réussir à atteindre une certaine forme
de vérité dieu et moi j'aurais tendance
à avoir un petit peu le même
raisonnement qui fait que c'est pas très
grave si chaque individu est biaisé
alors je sais que c'est pas du tout et
eti que c'est pas du tout c'est pas du
tout les idées qu'on entend sur internet
mais moi j'ai tendance à penser que
c'est pas grave si les individus restent
biaisé d'une certaine façon rester
rationnel
ce qu'il faut c'est garder suffisamment
de diversité pour que différents
individus et des idées différentes est
qu'une fois qu'ils vont débattre on
puisse émerger à une certaine forme de
vérité par exemple ya des expériences
qui montre que les gens quand ils sont
en groupe ils ont beaucoup plus de
facilité à résoudre une énigme
un problème de raisonnement que quand
ils sont tous seuls et ça typiquement on
explique parce que ils vont chacun
émettre des hypothèses et ils vont
chacun et chacun produire des arguments
pour soutenir ces hypothèses et à la fin
alors je sais que c'est un peu contre
intuitif parce qu'on a l'impression que
c'est toujours une polarisation des gens
etc
mais il existe certains cas certaines
situations dans lesquelles les avis ne
sont pas plus polarisé à la fin d'un
débat mais les gens sont arrivés
vraiment à changer au moins un petit peu
leurs amis il ya plusieurs cas où je
suis totalement d'accord avec ça
notamment par exemple au niveau de la
recherche va être un petit coin de la
recherche
pratiquement il ya ce débat théorie des
cordes gravité quantique à boucles
j'ai pas si pas si tu as entendu par s
attaque et de grandes cultures
rapidement quoi on va viril il ya un peu
cette idée qu'il ya plusieurs approches
mais pas et je prends le continent mais
j'ai entendu que j'ai vu les vidéos de
david là dessus grâce à lui j'ai entendu
même en dehors de ces exemples si ça
arrive souvent qu'il ya plusieurs
strates qui ferait plusieurs théories
qui sont développés par différents
groupes de chercheurs et chacun voit un
peu son onglet convaincu que ce monde et
est au moins à pas mal de valeur et
c'est une bonne chose parce que ça ça
favorise la diversité
puis si jamais c'est un modèle
s'effondre ben on a plein de
d'alternatives qui nous reste après du
coup avoir chacun qui croît de façon un
peu irrationnel que son modèle est le
bon parce qu'il faut quand même de la
motivation pour se lancer dans un défaut
noté quantique à boucles
ce n'est pas un petit peu irrationnelle
par rapport à la possibilité que ce soit
vrai c'est un peu moqué et du coup dans
ce cadre là c'est assez intéressant
il ya un autre cadre qu'elle que je
pensais ses niveaux de l'altruisme
efficace qui a rouvert tribune le
directeur de recherche à réticent à voir
qui est qui réfléchit beaucoup voient la
question les recherches notamment à
faire et en quelles sont les meilleures
façons d'être altruiste et s qui disait
c'est que il ya des choses qui sont très
bien connus
voire très bien acceptée et qui ont un
peu consensus dans la communauté a très
efficace typiquement les trucs de malade
la malaria typiquement le genre mais
c'est des trucs qui sont vraiment sûrs
et on connaît vraiment bien et ce qui
manquera pas ce qui ce qui est presque
il dit c'est des gens qui sont capables
d'explorer des trucs qui ont peu de
chance de marcher ou qui ont peu de
chances d'être un vrai problème mais
comme comme maison peu de chance
rationnellement on a envie de dire que
c'est pas ça il faut faire parce que bon
a priori c'est un peu de chance mais
comme il ya plein de choses où il ya peu
de chances que ce soit soit une super
solution soit un truc catastrophique
qu'il faut régler le fait que chacun
croit son petit truc ou voit son petit
bout de chemin de façon un petit peu
irrationnel et ne cherche pas à voir sa
vision d'ensemble permet cette
exploration de plein d'idées différentes
ouais je comprends le contrat c'est une
célébration de la diversité le message
général
ouais et comme on fonctionne beaucoup à
la motivation est comme le motivation
vient souvent des raisonnements motivé
malheureusement en fait le raisonnement
motivé permet cette exploration voici le
meilleur rookie quoi aussi pour explorer
des trucs que sinon si on réfléchit
c'est la rose un peu de chance après je
pense que ceci être conscient veut bon
d'être conscient de ça est bon parce que
dans certains cas en effet je pense que
c'est très utile mais je pense qu'aussi
dans notre cas fait d'avoir une vision
biaisée voit typiquement dans des débats
je sais pas quels sont les débats
auxquels tu pensais mais dont beaucoup
de débats houleux c'est à dire sur
twitter twitter et qu'est-ce qui est les
débats se passent pas forcément très
bien on va dire ouais ouais je suis bien
sûr connaissait problème je vais les
connaître de plus en plus bien mais
c'est quoi
j'ai du mal en fait à pointer du doigt
la différence qu'il existe entre ces
deux situations justement pourquoi dans
certaines situations on ne trouve que
c'est ok d'être biaisé et dans d'autres
situations on trouve que c'est pas ok de
biaiser j'ai du mal à mettre le doigt
vraiment sûr sur cette différence
l'impression que j'ai pratiqué dans les
exemples que je t'ai cité ce qui al'air
fait il ya besoin de beaucoup de
spécialisation et il semble que être
biaisé un peu irrationnel soit
indispensable aux désirs de
spécialisation d'accord et donc en
particulier en particulier quand tu dois
produire toi-même de la connaissance ce
serait plutôt ok mais par exemple quand
tu dois te faire ton avis sur une
question qui devra familière t'as pas
besoin d'être spécialisé du coup là il
faudrait éviter d'être mise et ce serait
ça le wep a pas typiquement il faudra
mieux faire une vite analysé comprend
des reculs ouais ouais ouais pourquoi
pas en tout cas où elle la psychologie
pas vraiment pour moi avoir une
importance énorme dans cette question du
changement climatique dans les questions
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure de
d'expliquer aux gens que c'est pas grave
s'il ya des différences cognitive entre
les gens ce qui est important c'est de
traiter les gens de la même de la même
façon quoi de donner les mêmes droits à
tout le monde
de oued dans tout en fait dans le mieux
vivre dans le mieux vivre ensemble comme
diraient nos politiques
la psychologie a son mot à dire ouais
mais tu vois pas ce qu'un des trucs qui
me semblait très beau les problématiques
niveau de la psychologie du système qui
menace est c'est fait maintenant ça
compartimente alizés à utiliser des
arguments quand ça nous arrange pas
typiquement l'exemple de deux du
changement climatique et du glyphosate
bâle et sion se positionne sur les 2 et
plupart des gens se positionnent pas
prennent les conclusions scientifiques
dans l'un et pas dans l'autre - et
supporte la science ne se dissoud à la
73e lorsque cela les arrange
ouais et du coup on a tendance à avoir
des décombres dès qu'on a le sujet à
utiliser les outils c'est un peu de la
racialisation mais c'est le fait que les
psychologues face aux 6,7
compartimentalisation étudie la
psychologie
ils ont fermé leur ordinateur ne semble
pas rassurant ou satisfaisants
[Musique]
ah oui mais la biologie de l'évolution
elle s'en fout de ce qui rassure encore
[Musique]
passé je veux dire oui c'est pas
rassurant mais c'est comme ça quand on
n'y peut rien quoi est ce qu'en dit plus
rien non non non je veux pas dire on n'y
peux rien je retire je veux dire c'est
une question empirique qu'est ce qu'on y
peut voilà c'est ça le truc mais ce qui
est certain c'est que ça va être très
dur d'aller contre sa psychologie évolue
d'ailleurs si je dis pas de bêtises ait
dans son dans son bouquin je sais plus
comment il s'appelle son bouquin je
vomis les héritiers semaine
voilà c'est ça il me semble qu'ils que
lui il est plutôt pour il est plutôt
pour faire confiance à son éléphant il
est plutôt dans l'optique essayer de
changer les gens en jouant sur
l'éléphant tu vois donc plutôt la
stratégie ne doit de la stratégie
réflexive imposé essayez de signy vais
essayer de d'avoir du self contrôle sur
ces sur ses instincts et c est vraiment
un peu deux écoles qui s'affrontent
après les deux approches sont pas avec
complémentaire à 6 mois louis conte plus
complètement elles peuvent être
complémentaires et je pense aussi c'est
un truc où il ya où il ya de la
variabilité individuelle s'est passé pas
je pense qu'il ya des études qui
montrent que cette capacité à avoir du
self control c'est là aussi des bases
biologiques dans quasiment tout cas
alors on peut le travailler évidemment
on peut travailler sur cette contrôle
mais il ya aussi certaines personnes qui
sont beaucoup plus doué pour poursine iv
quoi pour avoir du self control que
d'autres et ça il faut le prendre en
compte tu as situe ici c'est parce qu'il
fait passer une loi ou
pour que les gens y lisait beaucoup plus
de self control il faut prendre en
compte le fait qu'il ya certaines
personnes elle n'y arriveront pas même
avec tout le toute la bonne volonté du
monde n'arriveront pas à augmenter leur
salle lors simple contrôle mais on va
entrer dans des zones un peu encore un
peu progressé parce que tu vous pourrez
proposer des façons d'amener les gens à
voir 17 contrôler différentes en
fonction sur des vues sur des bases
biologiques
ça se rapproche un petit peu de droits
différents
[Musique]
moi je n'appellerais pas ça des droits
j'appellerais ça des des outils
différents
en fait tu donne aux gens des outils
différents des outils qui sont adaptés à
chaque personne pour qu'il puisse
changer leur comportement s'ils en ont
envie bien sûr ça ne s'agit pas de
forcer les gens mais voilà il ya plutôt
ça déjà perez a plutôt des outils que
des droits est typiquement toutes été
votées les loups relu mon script et du
coup une tête a vu aussi ma vidéo sur
biaisé l'algorithme de youtube pour
faire des recommandations plus éducative
où j'ai pas vous avez bien encore
s'était basé sur ce script la whey donc
du coup l idée que je propose est donc
cessé d'avoir ce qu'aujourd'hui youtube
fait des recommandations qui sont
personnalisées qui ont différents
utilisateurs à l'autre et il ya beaucoup
d'études qui montrent que très
rapidement les vidéos et plus viral sont
pas forcément les plus éducative et ils
sont souvent ceux qui promeuvent des
idées très addictif comme par exemple
les idées conspirationnistes où les
idées très indignés ou très énervé il ya
plein de problèmes par rapport à tout ça
et du coup ce que je suggérais dans
cette vidéo c'est 2
d'avoir de modifier cet algorithme de
recommandations pour qui recommande
davantage par exemple des vidéos
éducatives ou des vidéos qui ont une
vision à long terme
des vidéos qui sont plus réfléchis ainsi
de suite qu'est ce que tu penses de ça
si moi j'aime bien j'aime j'aime bien
l'idée alors à quand redonne mois trois
secondes pour réfléchir avec mon petit
cerveau de juger juste bon en fait c'est
une vision des choses qui va exactement
dans ce sens de de penser qu' on va
réussir à inhiber notre psychologie
évoluer quoi il est possible d'inhiber
sa psychologie évoluer par le
raisonnement etc
je dis ça dans le sens où les vidéos
dont tu parles les vidéos
conspirationnistes les vidéos qui font
du clash etc
si elles sont 6 après 6,6 y apprécier si
regardez c'est parce qu'elles plaisent à
notre psychologie intuitive tu vois pas
ce qu'on vit même bien le clash on aime
bien
bon ça nous amènerait dans un autre
sujet mais les conspirations en fait ça
c'est en fait à employer le terme d'
addiction
il ya des gens qui emploie le terme de
parasites
ils disent que les théories
conspirationnistes des parasites de
notre cerveau parce que elle arrive à
exploiter des la façon dont notre
cerveau est organisé pour aller
s'implanter dans notre cerveau des
théories qui sont très plaisants très
plaisante pour un cerveau humain
donc tout ça toutes les vidéos qui sont
pour l'instant mises en avant par
youtube en fait ce sont des vidéos qui
parlent à notre psychologie intuitive et
si tu mettais en place si tu proposer
d'autres vidéos qui sont plus réflexive
tu ferais le pari que en parlant à notre
psychologie réflexif tu arriveras à
changer notre psychologie intuitive ou
ce genre de choses
donc moi je suis moi ça me ferait donc
là c'était une idée que je danse un peu
comme ça des vidéos réflexive mais ça
pourrait être aussi des vidéos
des notes quads électriques qui sait de
tous c'est petit à petit les gens alors
est sans doute une réflexion
intéressante pour les psychologues
autour de quels sont les vidéos a
recommandé pour amener les gens à mieux
réfléchir par exemple prendre conscience
de leur système
ouais ouais je voyais sit in situ ouais
si tu passes des bonnes vidéos de negage
ça devient peut-être plus intéressant
pour pourquoi pas parce que parce que là
là là il y aurait un moyen via la
gouaille de recommandations de youtube
d'avoir quasiment une implication
directe des travaux de psychologues sur
comment surtout su comment réfléchit
potentiellement comment mieux réfléchir
avec une application directe pour qui
s'appliquerait potentiellement des
meilleurs de l'utilisateur non monsieur
je suis d'accord avec toi que youtube
c'est vraiment un levier énorme et
pourquoi pas s'en servir
pourquoi parce que je lisais un autre
endroit que je disais ça que en fait on
a déjà l'état par exemple qui fait
passer des messages à ses populations à
la télé par deux par des pubs
ils vont te dire manger bouger voilà
manger cinq fruits et légumes on le fait
déjà à la à la télé donc dans un sens je
trouve pas ça si choquant que l'état d'
swaps et youtube soit force youtube pour
faire passer des messages d'utilité
publique
je trouve pas l'idée si choquant que ça
après après voilà les messages à faire
passer c'est voile sur le contenu des
messages qu'il faut vraiment bien
réfléchir est ce qu'on veut faire passer
des messages plutôt réflexif qui vont
peut-être parler qu'à une certaine
catégorie de la population ou est-ce
qu'on fait passer plutôt dans des
messages de nadj qui jouent sur des
ficelles de notre psychologie évolué
là est la question
et du coup bien vu que tu as beaucoup lu
du coup été très sensibilisé à ces
problèmes de différents modes de pensée
ce que t'as pas parfait impression est
tarifé schizophrène d'avoir moi ça va
mais c'est un appel du pied ou par voie
je suis publiquement et je le parle du
mois du présent du mois du passé 10 mois
puisque plus d'une fois il voit pas
réfléchi du mois ouais ouais je pars en
fait je suis un peu comme les
psychologues dont je te parlais tout à
l'heure je pense que c'est peut-être un
peu dommage mais quand je ferme mon
ordinateur je me remets à penser de
façon normale
c'est peut-être pas plus malin tu vois
c'est un peu comme la vidéo sur les
zombies sommes nous des zombies de
monsieur fils tu regardes une
vidéothèque tu te convaincre que tuer un
zombie
voilà que la conscience n'est qu'une
illusion c'est peut-être pas plus mal
que quand tu fermes les sites la vidéo
dure parce qu'ils reçoivent sur le mode
bon ben je suis pas un zombie tout va
bien du coup peut-être que par analogie
ce n'est peut-être pas plus mal non plus
de rechute chez sur les billets de
raisonnement des petits fermiers vidéo
je pense qu'il ya des étés titien qui se
retourner ouais mais même les été tissé
un peu au dessus je suis quasiment
certain que s'il ya des études qui ont
été faites
elles vont nous montrer que les et
éthicien dans la vie de tous les jours
ils sont pas plus ça ils le sont
peut-être mais à tout
peut-être qu'ils sont plus rationnels
que les autres dans la vie de tous les
jours mais en tout cas ils seront encore
sujet à tout un tas de billets je vais
bien j'ai quasiment certain de cinq ans
vous voilà est schizophrène mais je
pense que c'est une bonne chose de se
contrôler un à mon avis ouais si
j'essayais de résumer mon avis je pense
que pour ceux qui arrivent c'est pas
donné à tout le monde mais pour ceux qui
arrivent ce qui arrive à inhiber leur
psychologie évolué je pense que la
majeure partie du temps c'est une bonne
chose
alain m&g si j'essaie de travailler un
peu là dessus mais voilà c'est pas
facile du tout mais bon moi ouais
l'expérience du mois du futur mois du
passé moi je la fais dans le cas de la
morale mais on en avait discuté sur
twitter je me je me demande je me
demande parfois je regarde des émissions
de télé qu'on regarde et quand on était
à dole avec des trucs à la con la gagne
fille caméra café des petits trucs
friends les séries quoi les séries qui
ont regardé et tout c'est toutes ces
séries elles sont bourrés de stéréotypes
sexistes des blagues parfois racistes
des trucs qui passeraient plus
aujourd'hui à la télé m1 6,6 à passer à
la télé aujourd'hui ça ferait un
scandale immédiatement et je me vis à
l'époque non seulement regarder mais ça
ne choquait pas et ça ne faisait rien et
du coup moi la question que je me pose
c'est dans 10 ou 20 ans quels seront les
choses que je pense que je fais
aujourd'hui qui me feront le même effet
il est dans ce sens là où chez un peu
schizophrène monde à mon avis les les
les candidats les plus probables c'est
là c'est l'aviron de la consommation de
viande
c'est tout ce qui concerne le climat
donc les déplacements en voiture les
voyages en avion pour aller en week end
un madrier douchez pas vous tous à mon
avis je me considérais comme un sale
type quand je regarderai tout ça dans le
futur quoi d'autre celle c'est vraiment
une expérience de pensée de très dur à
faire vraiment très dur à faire vis à
vis des conséquences nationales puis
pratique
comment savoir mouais si je pense que ça
a eu des conséquences parce que quand tu
réfléchis en fait dans les cas moreau il
ya des beaucoup d'expérience qui
montrent que les gens ils peuvent
changer d'avis sur des questions morales
quand tu leur présente de nouvelles
informations par exemple basse à cenon
d'en parler ce dont on parle est par
exemple tu vois tu vois dans une série
un gars mettre une main au cul à une
meuf à l'époque on en rigolait peut-être
parce qu'on n'avait pas assez
d'informations mais à partir du moment
où on a eu par exemple les réseaux
sociaux qui nous ont informés qu'ils
nous ont dit que ben c'est bon d'une
parcelle
c'est vraiment pas drôle pour une meuf
qu'elles se prennent ça à longueur de
journée que ça cause vraiment des torts
à des gens tu vois là tu commence
vraiment à changer d'avis sur le point
sur le point moral donc c'est en
apprenant il ya des expériences qui
montrent que en apprenant des nouvelles
informations on arrive à changer d'avis
sur des questions morales et donc je
pense que réfléchir à ces questions les
questions sur ce que je sais que je dois
manger comment je dois me comporter
comment je dois me déplacer
ça permet de faire évoluer nos
intuitions moral plus rapidement les
réseaux sociaux c'est un os est un autre
moyen jeu je dis souvent que même si
c'est vrai qu'on a cette idée que les
réseaux sociaux c'est un peu le mal
quoique tout le monde se tire dessus et
se prend la gueule que c'est un combat
permanent sur twitter les réseaux
sociaux ça permet aussi d'échanger de
l'information d'échanger de
l'information notamment sur les torts
qu'on cause aux minorités parfois même
sans le savoir
et du coup à mon avis les réseaux
sociaux ça joue aussi un rôle très
important dans la lutte contre les
discriminations donc dans le changement
des jugements moraux et c'est ce qu'on
peut voir avec mitu par exemple pour moi
le mouvement mis tout si j'essaie de
comprendre ce que c'est c'est un
mouvement où les gens ou le goulet où on
s'est mis a échangé beaucoup
d'informations et en particulier à un
moment où les femmes se sont se sont
vraiment mis à dire que elles
subissaient ces discriminations tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps etc
sont vraiment apporté une nouvelle
information sur des torts qu'on leur
cause en permanence et c'est ça qui
amène des changements de jugements
moraux selon moi donc là pour répondre à
ta question je pense que réfléchir à ces
problématiques ça fait évoluer plus vite
mais c'est les changements ces idées et
les impacts certains à vivre pratiquer
ouais si si carrément enfin je pense
être c'est toujours très dur de dire que
c'est ça la cause mais par exemple quand
j'étais en thèse je choisisse et à
peut-être fait la même chose je choisis
c'est l'endroit où j'allais donner des
conférences en fonction de à quel point
l'endroit était loin de la france par
exemple tu vois je ne disais je vais pas
les donner une conférence
en suisse la lausanne c'est tout pourri
je préfère aller donner une conférence à
miami
évidemment impact carbone vraiment
vraiment pourri et aujourd'hui je ferai
plus jamais ce à quoi même même allé
donner une conférence en avion en suisse
je pense que je le ferais pas là ouais
la viande n'est pas encore vraiment
réussi si j'ai réussi à diminuer g
diminue énormément ma consommation de
viande mais j'ai pas arrêté complètement
voilà je ne sais pas si c'est toutes ces
réflexions qui sont qui sont la cause de
ces changements de comportement mais je
pense web pour moi ça il ya contribué
ils sont peut-être eu des effets sans
doute sa tâche n à toi m'a dit tant que
temps que tant que tu réfléchis à ta
question là si la chaîne de monsieur
fils et de la science taché natoye c'est
de la psychologie je trouve
en fait ce qui va prendre ça pour une
insulte mais pour moi tu es suis un
psychologue c'est vrai que je suis pas
un géologue ça c'est pas la pire insulte
quoi est en fait très souvent quand je
regarde des vidéos je me dis mais il
n'est pas du tout en train de parler de
maths ou je sais pas quoi il est en
train de parler de psychologie et de
comportements humains
tu vois par exemple il fait une série
sur la démocratie tu parles d'un petit
peu de théorie des jeux pour faire
semblant que ça met tout de suite tu
reviens à parler d'eux c'est quoi la
justice
comment changer le système de vote etc
tu fais une série sur l'intelligence
artificielle ouais tu parle un peu de de
turing etc
toutes ces conneries là pour faire
semblant que c'est des maths et tout de
suite tu reviens sur la morale des îles
en fait je devrais je pensais pas c'est
pas un hasard si vous parlez souvent de
dos maux fabulous à axium c'est parce
qu'en fait on a les mêmes centres
d'intérêt qui est la compréhension du
comportement humain est donc voilà si tu
revenais si tu devais dire quelque chose
à ton mois devient 50 une vraie lui dire
d'étudier le psychologisme ans va pas
voir le moment du passé je te fais pas
confiance
j'avais une autre j'ai pour moi du passé
mais carmes antiga attendant livre de la
série en quoi surveille les jeux que
j'ai parlé de la règle enfin la
réflexion qui me fascine c'est
c'est qu'est-ce que réfléchir comment
mieux réfléchir et comment je peux mieux
réfléchir en particulier et aussi
comment je peux amener les autres à
mieux réfléchir c'est beaucoup et
finalement les questions qui me fascine
sont très proches de la psychologie mais
pas que ça c'est qui va si la formule de
baisse qui considère ça qu'on avait
comme des psychologies
si tu réponds oui je suis prêt à venir
entre retourner dans le passé à dire
qu'on veut du passé et illico logique tu
demanderais à de haan
il te dirai c'est de la psychologie tout
cas quand j'ai vu le cours de deux de
stanislas dehaene sur le cerveau
parisien mais c'est dit j'aimerais dire
ma thèse dans son domaine ouais ouais
non mais c'est sûr tu aurais trouvé
passionnant
d'ailleurs c'est un bon point pour la
formule de bayes le fait que que la
sélection naturelle
elle est choisie entre guillemets
j'utilise un langage finalistes mais on
sait tous de quoi on parle que la
sélection naturelle elle ait choisi
d'implémenter la formule de beille dans
nos cerveaux c'est bon point enfin moi
ça je trouve ça convaincant point non
moins formidable et je trouve ça très
beau très cool et le fait qu'elle n'ait
pas fait le fait qu'elle n'est pas fait
pour le raisonnement par contre le fait
que de façon très flexible ce soit très
dur de faire de petits qu'est la formule
de baise c'est aussi un très bon point
pour dire que le réseau le but du
raisonnement c'est pas du tout de de
chercher la vérité de prendre des bonnes
décisions quoi aucun nom serait que 6 et
qu'on peut en effet enfin bon voila si
jamais tu veux en parler un jour
rejoindre le groupe des psychologues
anonymes ou je sais pas quoi
comme des petits que je serai là pour
toi après tout cas ce qui me fascine
dans pas mal de succès que très
rapidement on l'enverra plein de
questions interdisciplinaire sur sur
toutes ces questions parce que la
section se posent des question de
comment on va y réfléchir faisait un peu
en posant la question de comment mieux
réfléchir j'en suis venu à me poser des
questions sur la morale parce que je
suis pas quelqu'un de très préoccupé par
la morale de base mais je suis devenu en
réfléchissant à ça et du coup petit à
petit vous connecter sur la morale puis
après de laetita risme puis après de
l'actrice d'une efficace et puis du coup
à prendre poser question babac du
couvent pratique qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour changer le monde et puis du
coup ça pose des questions de d'écologie
développement durable et tout ça et ça
pose ensuite des questions
d'environnement et puis d'economie très
rapidement en fait on se rend compte que
tout est vert important malheureusement
ce groupe a pour pour pour mieux
réfléchir et mieux préparer le futur et
l'humanité
ouais complètement façon sauf la
géologie mouvement sauf l'avion est
encore la dernière fois je réfléchissais
à ça mais la géologie elle a
probablement était beaucoup plus
important il faut pas le dire
évidemment ça dans ce podcast mais la
géologie elle a eu probablement une
importance énorme sur l'évolution
humaine que ce soit tu pas que ce soit
le pôle le passage de forêts tropicales
à un paysage de savane qui nous à nous à
perdre une fin qui nous a pas permis
mais qui a créé une pression de
sélection pour de faire évoluer la
bipédie etc
la géologie probablement une force
majeure dans l'évolution humaine
on va pas le dire trop fort tori de
parler d'été et étaient en vie et
géologiques géologue
si toi tu es un psychologue refoulé moi
je suis un géologue refoulé on peut
aller tout doucement vers la conclusion
du podcast à monter d'autres choses à
rajouter d'autres disciplines à
descendre ou ce genre de temps qu'à se
faire des amis autant y aller quoi non
je crois que c'est tout du coup quel est
le message clé que tu aimerais que les
auditeurs du podcast routier nous alors
le message clé ça c'est facile c'est le
message clis le message que je vais
martelé tout le temps dans les années
qui viennent s'est arrêtée de nier
l'existence de différences
psychologiques entre individus même si
elles ont des origines biologiques
battez-vous simplement pour que tous les
individus aient les mêmes droits quels
que soient leurs différences
c'est vraiment ça le message que je veux
que je veux faire passer c'est vraiment
plus qu'un message c'est vraiment une
supplication quoi il faut se rendre
compte que le raisonnement selon lequel
pour que deux individus aient les mêmes
droits
ils doivent être exactement les mêmes
c'est vraiment un raisonnement qu'a pas
de sens on attendit du coup un peu sur
sas et je pense qu'un des trucs une
raison pour laquelle ce genre de
messages et n'ai pas apprécié de tout le
monde sait que je pense qu'il ya une
confusion récurrentes sur entre ce que
les chaussons et ce qu'elle devrait être
la guillotine 2 avec deux films dont a
parlé précédemment
et du coup beaucoup de gens pensent que
ce qui devrait être est plus ou moins ce
qui est je trouve qu'on appelait et bon
bref
et du coup certaines personnes pensent
beaucoup de gens même la plupart des
gens ont tendance à penser que vu qu'il
ya des différences biologiques ça
justifie les différences créé il y as
été biologique justifierait des
inégalités je prête aux richesses ou
deux autres parce que c'est ce message à
qui passer cette idée là ces confusions
entre être et devrait être qui fait que
les gens ont vraiment beaucoup de mal
avec
et quand il se dit quand tu dis les gens
tu es en train de parler des racistes
tout est en train de parler des gens qui
se battent déjà contre les
discriminations par exemple je pense les
deux à la fois je pense que beaucoup de
beaux coups de masse grasse on
enfoncerait confusion passer sa
confiance qui pas si j'ai mis du temps à
découvrir la guillotine de yum et quand
on pense que tant qu'on a pas su
beaucoup réfléchi à des fondements de la
morale et caustique les fondements de la
morale ça pas de raison d'être
quelques le monde eh oui mais par
exemple le fait que si on a des noirs et
des blancs les noirs les noirs et les
blancs doivent avoir les mêmes droits
que ça c'est un raisonnement qui coule
de source pour plein de gens qui se
battent contre des discriminations c'est
pas parce qu'on a des noirs et des
blancs qu'on doit faire de différence de
traitement
donc c'est la même chose non tu ferais
une différence entre les entre les deux
je pense que ceux qui font beaucoup de
gens qui défendent l'égalité noir et
blanc rajouterai quand même qu' il n'y a
pas ça reste la même espérance où je
pensais il reste humain on reste rien
côté d'un fonds un peu égalitariste
biologique sous jacent raisonnement de
couy doivent avoir les mêmes droits
du coup ce sont pas des sous-humains par
exemple ce mardi d ouais
ouais moi je suis pas trop quoi dire mon
moi dans mon état actuel je trouve que
ce raisonnement est vraiment n'a aucun
sens mais comme tu dis c'est peut-être
parce que j'ai réfléchi depuis un moment
si je fais c'est de pousser sur les
différences entre différentes espèces
animales ce que tu penses que pardon
quand je suis à devra avoir une droits
qu'un humain non et du coup on peut peut
demain si on veut essayer de tomber t on
peut se dire voilà la même façon qu'un
chien a pas les mêmes droits qu'un
requin blanc pourquoi est-ce que qu'un
homme me dire pourquoi est ce qu'une
femme devra voir lien droits qu'un homme
parce que on lui donne dans ce cas là tu
pourrais très bien dire pourquoi donner
le
les mêmes droits au noir et au blanc le
dire dans ce cas là tu deviendras que tu
deviens effectivement raciste moi le moi
en fait le message que je veux pas faire
passer c'est plutôt à tous ces gens qui
lutte déjà contre les discriminations
qui sont capables dans énormément de
situations de voir que des différences
ne justifie pas des discriminations tout
de suite quand on parle du psychologique
elles sont plus capables de faire la
différence quand c'est ça devient
vraiment bizarre après je suis d'accord
que en théorie un raciste il pourrait
dire dès qu'il ya une différence
on peut la transformer en discrimination
mais pour tous les gens normaux entre
guillemets tous les gens qui se battent
contre les discriminations s'il va être
s'ils veulent être cohérent avec le
raisonnement je pense qu'il faut que
j'accepte le fait que c'est pas grave
qu'il ya des différences entre individus
qu'on est plus tout à l'heure ce que je
disais sur le fait que si tu reconnais
pas qu'il ya des différences battu
crétois même de la discrimination parce
que tu prend plus en compte les
particularités des individus il ya aussi
un problème dont j'ai pas parlé c'est
que le fait en fait les c'est que le
fait que les gens ils haïssent et
ensuite ils trouvent des raisons pour
l'heure pour le pour leur haine fêté 50
la psychologie c'est que les gens ils
comme c'est exactement le raisonnement
motiver les gens ils commencent par haïr
et ensuite ils vont aller trouver des
raisons si la science dit que si les
gens haïssent les noirs et que la
science dit que les noirs sont
différents génétiquement bon ils vont
prendre cette raison mais si ce n'était
pas cette raison-là t'inquiète pas
qu'ils en trouvera une autre
et d'ailleurs les connaissances
génétiques et biologiques sur les
comportements humains
on les a depuis seulement quelques
années quelques dizaines d'années mais
les discriminations elles sont pas
apparus ces dernières années ces
dizaines d'années ça fait des siècles
fait des millénaires que les femmes par
exemple sont discriminés tu allais les
gens les gens les gens qui veulent haïr
un autre groupe de gens ils trouveront
toujours un moyen de faire peu importe
d'où viennent peu importe l'origine des
différences quoi et du coup je pense que
le insisté sur la guillotine de youtube
parce que c'est peut-être un point
important
ouais ouais je sais je sais pas si c'est
un point dur à comprendre moi je le
trouve assez intuitif mais c'est
peut-être pas si facile que ça à
comprendre parce que les gens dans leur
tête la morale en fait c'est tellement
intuitif on revient toujours à cette
histoire que c'est un module évolué qui
est partie intégrante de nos
psychologies c'est tellement intuitif
qu'on moralise le monde tout le temps en
permanence quoi on a du mal à se sortir
de ça on a du mal à envisager le monde
d'une façon qui ne soit pas morale et du
coup je sais pas si pour des gens des
personnes lambda cette distinction cette
guillotine de youm el soit si intuitive
je pense que la plupart des gens diront
jamais entendu parler me disais
similaires
quant à moi j'ai mis beaucoup de temps
avant découvert ça et après il ya
l'utiliser en pratique je veux dire
ouais suffit pas d'en avoir entendu
parler c'est un truc les psychologues
savent très bien je sais pas je leur
demanderai ouais tu es seul ça prend du
temps avant d'intérioriser de prendre
tout ça moi non c'est certain c'est
certain qu'il ya du pain sur la planche
du coup pour finir à ce que tu pourrais
faire de recommandations de vidéos
podcasts livres ou personnes à suivre
ouais je vais faire de livres le premier
c'est je suis obligé de dire le gène
égoïste de richard dawkins parce que
pour moi c'est facile et déjà dit ça a
été une grosse claque dans la gueule
c'est je pense la plus belle idée
scientifique que j'ai rencontrés dans
toute ma vie alors c'est pareil que
darwin acs s'est pas il propose pas une
théorie fondamentalement différente mais
propose une théorie qui est vraiment
centré sur le gène et puis comme il
donne plein d'exemples il c'est un bon
vulgarisateur c'est vraiment
avec le gène égoïste que tu te prends
une claque plus qu'avec l'origine des
espèces donc je recommanderais ça
vraiment à toutes les personnes qui
connaissent pas et puis si jamais je
sais pas si j'avais vous prenez pas de
claques tue pas pas si cela veut dire
ouais non peut-être qu'il ya des gens
qui sont pas prêts pour certaines idées
ou qui sait pas forcément qu'ils la
comprennent pas
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
comprennent pas vraiment la théorie de
l'évolution
même si ça s'explique en merci à
s'explique en trois phrases comme les
raisonnements finalistes sont très
intuitifs ils reprennent tout de suite
le dessus donc je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui disent qu'ils
croient en la théorie de l'évolution
mais qui n'ont pas bien compris comment
ça marche en tête s'est longtemps été
bouquin c'est à dire que toi tu croyez
quoi je pense que j'avais une idée très
floue de ce qui était une évolution
comment pendant longtemps je pense y
compris aux puits c'est au moment où je
pensais à vulgariser différents sujets
du gard ise la théorie d'évolution que
j'ai vraiment creuser un peu plus le
sujet où tu habites avait l'idée vague
que les êtres vivants ils sont tous
reliés et qu'ils ont évolué et voilà
qu'on a tous rêvé d'un ancêtre non voilà
c'est ça je pense que j'avais cette idée
après il ya je pense qu'il ya toujours
un peu de finalisme un peu cette idée
les choses sont pour à un but culminera
derrière tout ça que kiki et qui rend
difficile vraiment rejeter hors
effacement une claque plus aux coups de
poing ou confort très sceptique ça c'est
sûr je sais que moi
le jour où j'ai compris ce que tu viens
de dire là que les mutations arrive par
hasard qu'il n'y a pas de finale
je me rappelle encore aujourd'hui
j'étais j'étais au lycée en cours d'être
vite et ça mal ça m'a tellement marqué
que je m'en rappelle comme on se
rappelle de l'endroit où on est
au moment du 11 septembre ou au moment
des attentats de charlie charlie hebdo
tueur ça a été tellement un
bouleversement à ce moment là dans ma
façon de comprendre le monde et les
êtres vivants que je me rappelle encore
exactement où j'étais quel endroit quand
j'ai appris cette idée là quoi quand je
me suis rendu compte que la nation était
aléatoire mais après presque l'autre
truc qui est peut-être plus parce que
peut-être j'avais une idée un petit peu
intuitif ans on va complètement juste
mais le truc qui m'a vraiment frappé
quand j'ai conservé la risée jeu que
j'avais écrit un billet de blog ces
rétributions et s'est lézardé enfin le
raisonnement de darwin notamment sur les
îles des galapagos avec les différents
soysal et les différents oiseaux
c'est ce genre de raisonnement je suis
reste axée sur ses jolies parce que
c'est un beau raisonnement
ouais ouais c'est ouais c'est magnifique
ouais enfin voilà bref dawkins pour mon
premier livre est le deuxième livre en
fait je recommanderais bien justin
textbook de psychologie évolutionnaire
en fait à n'importe qui qui est
intéressé par cette question donc les
textes book on en a déjà parlé cd des
livres qui sont souvent écrits pour le
niveau licence et qui sont qui sont
assez approfondies qui vous qui sont
assez approfondi mais qui sont quand
même un niveau relativement relativement
simple pour les gens même qu'ils ne
lisent pas beaucoup de sens pour les
gens qui sont pas chercheur quand ils
peuvent quand même le lien et je
recommanderai dire ça donc pour ceux qui
s'intéressent à la psychologie
évolutionnaire mais aussi juste pour
montrer à quel point toutes les
critiques qu'on fait généralement à la
psychologie évolutionnaire elles sont
pas fondées c'est à dire que par exemple
on renie pas du tout leur hold
de la culture ou de l'éducation ou de
l'environnement on dit pas du tout qu'il
ya du déterminisme géologique je connais
aucun psychologue aucun biologiste qui
dit qu'il ya du déterminisme génétique
et dans tous les bouquins de psychologie
évolutionnaire tu vas trouver souvent un
chapitre entier sur le rôle de
l'environnement de la culture etc pour
montrer qu'on a des méthodes aussi
puisque la psychologie évolutionnaire
est souvent attaqué sur ses méthodes on
en a discuté en tout début de podcasts
on a des méthodes qui consistent à
générer des hypothèses est ensuite allé
tester les prédictions que font ces
hypothèses et voilà pour montrer que
c'est un chant qui est un vrai champ de
scientifiques en fait d'ailleurs des
fois je le considère même pas comme une
discipline scientifique à part entière
je le considère juste comme soit un état
d'esprit et plus précisément comme un
moyen de je sais que ça fait un peu
cliché de dire ça mais précisément comme
comme un moyen de générer des hypothèses
un état d'esprit qui te permet de
générer des hypothèses que tu aurais pas
généré site avait pas eu cet état
d'esprit par contre après sur les
méthodes la psychologie évolutionnaire
elle n'a pas vraiment de méthodes
propres
tu vois quand tu va tester les
prédictions de théorie était en train de
faire de la psychologie classique ou de
biologie classique etc
donc je comprends fin pour moi la grande
majorité des critiques faites à cette
discipline sont vraiment infondées entre
autres parce que c'est pas vraiment une
discipline c'est juste une façon de
penser qu'ensuite on va se servir de
toutes les autres disciplines
scientifiques pour tester les hypothèses
si vous voulez rejeté la psychologie
évolutionnaire rejeté aussi la
cosmologie
ouais ouais carrément va leur jeter
toutes les disciplines qui étudie le
passé quoi il ya beaucoup de gens si
vous voulez être collé cohérents avec
leurs critiques et il devrait faire ça
et il n'y a pas de tant de textes bouka
lauriane 1 qui existe en français qui
s'appelle darwin en tête si les gens
veulent le lien je n'ai pas lu donc je
sais pas ce qu'il vaut mais
il a été écrit par des gens que j'estime
donc je pense qu'il doit être pas mal
darwin en tête et sinon en anglais il y
en a un qui est connue qui s'appelle
évolutionnaire l'ip psychology de new
south of the mind donc psychologie
évolutionnaire la nouvelle science de
l'esprit et moi on la suit la liste
trouve en pdf parfois super finir avec
une dernière question c'est quoi le
record de temps pas de casse n'ont rien
de problème c'est quoi le record de ton
podcast n'a pas ce que j'aurais voulu
battre le record nié par annie pas voilà
très neutre à 3 heures et je suis encore
à 3h40 avec rodolphe quelque chose comme
ça
tain mais rodolphe ouais ça les artistes
mais j'ai quand même quatre des ruines
question pour faire un peu flou est ce
que tu penses que la psychologie dans
l'est peut-être le biais cognitif et si
c'était un système de quelques principes
au moins de psychologie devrait être
enseigné à quel niveau acquis quelqu'un
qui est un cursus matin ce qui devrait
apprendre sonne ouais complètement je
mettrais moi je mettrais même la
psychologie au lycée en fait je pense
que toutes ces questions qui aide à
mieux réfléchir je l'aimé je le mets au
lycée du coup tu enlèves quoi fikri
sédhiou vent là quelque chose
d'après toile et la géologie faire ça on
enlève non mais en plus ça se transmet
en deux mots tu as ta pas besoin de
temps faire des tartines là tu as acheté
explique dans dans ces trois heures qui
viennent de passer j'ai dit
l'essentiel de ce que de ce que je
pensais de ce que je voulais dire qu'il
n'ya pas besoin de justes être
conscients qu'il existe des biais parlé
parlé du fait qu' il ya des origines
biologiques que c'est pas que du
culturel voilà c'est pas besoin d'en
faire des tartines
sinon je sinon je pense que ça devrait
être
oui oui en fait j'en ai pas parlé mais
une des raisons pour lesquelles j'ai
étudié je vais rallonger le podcast
attirer rallonge intégrer son repli en
fait une des raisons pour lesquelles
j'ai étudié choisi d'étudier les
sciences cognitives étudié le cerveau
humain donc je t'en ai dit tout à
l'heure c'est que je trouve que c'est un
défi formidable enfin c'est un des gros
défis de la science du 21e siècle notre
raison c'est que comme tout scientifique
ce qui m'intéresse de comprendre le
monde mais je voyais pas comment on
pouvait essayer de comprendre le monde
avant de commencer à comprendre la chose
qui nous sert à comprendre le monde qui
est le cerveau quoi dire que toutes les
informations qu'on reçoit sur le monde à
un moment donné elles vont passer par
notre cerveau elles vont être
interprétés par notre cerveau et donc
pour moi si je voulais vraiment content
comprendre le monde ne faut pas étudié
la physique théorique ou pas utilisés
l'origine de l'univers il faut étudier
vraiment le cerveau faut commencer par
ça donc ça rejoint ce que tu dis je
pense que tous les séries scientifiques
bénéficierez de cours sur la façon dont
fonctionne leur cerveau elle après il ya
la façon dont le cerveau fonctionne et
la façon dont il devrait fonctionner
voudront sera quoi je t'aide plus des
questions épistémologiques
même si yann ce qu'il faut prendre en
compte aussi des spécialités du cerveau
quand on fait ça va ya une citation que
j'adore ce de chercheurs préféré reis
l'aube 9
il disait un truc du genre
quand j'ai commencé à apprendre les
sciences et les mathématiques moi j'ai
trouvé ça génial et tout mais en fait
j'étais me suis rendu compte après coup
que j'étais beaucoup plus fascinés par
la manière dont on découvrait des
nouvelles théories et confirmé une
nouvelle théorie ou des nouvelles
théories mathématiques que par le
contenu découverte des sciences et des
mathématiques
ouais je vois je vois je vois
complètement moi je pensais plutôt
l'inversé j'ai l'impression d'être
plutôt passionné par les contenus que
par la façon de produire ces contenus
c'est un truc que je me dis souvent en
regardant des vidéos d'eux et éthiques
je me dis c'est super le boulot qu'ils
font évidemment c'est il faut en parler
néanmoins moi si tu me si tu me dis je
te donne une heure de temps libre la
séance que tu veux eh ben je vais la
passe est allé apprendre des contenus
scientifiques
allez comprendre comment fonctionne le
monde n'est pas à les comprendre et pas
à les comprendre comment produire la
connaissance que c'est un peu
contradictoire avec ce que j'ai dit à
l'instant j'ai l'impression que il faut
d'abord comprendre le cerveau pour
comprendre le monde
oui mais mais voilà c'est tout c'est
pour ces contradictions pour pour
montrer à quel point la psychologie est
compliqué voilà c'est un très beau très
bonne conclusion simple est ce qu'il va
pas j'ai rajouté encore un truc mais les
we qui fascine beaucoup les
mathématiciens c'est comment est ce
qu'on découvre des nouveaux terrains il
écrit à ses conduits de poincaré où le
livre de vie yannick export un peu ses
idées mais bon après celle ci mais je
pense que vraiment ça m'intrigue
facilement les mathématiciens parce que
en tant que mathématicien l'un des plus
beaux moments c'est quand on a une
valider mathématiquement découle tout à
coup au théorème du coup on a envie de
revivre ça forcément
du coup pas mal de questions sur comment
est ce qu'on fait pour y arriver en
premier lieu et je pense que c'est pas
très claires comme on irait mais non
c'est vrai
et alors tu es tellement bien trouver
des solutions tu penses que ce serait
possible car dans mon livre je relis
saadé des hypothèses liées au
bannissement le chantier âge on écarte
marco car l'om c'est une façon
d'explorer un espace est en fait si
c'est une façon d'explorer qui a aucune
garantie théorie paristic des garanties
coric à l'infini mais qui a aucune
ça finira par marcher c'est pas con et
en plus ce à quoi un mi chemin on est
incapable de dire si on a vraiment fait
du progrès bref c'est un truc que je
trouve assez fascinant et qui est
mentionné aussi par de sages de haine
dans son cours au collège de france donc
ça serait une partie en tout cas deux
explications mais je pense que pour moi
je réfléchis je pense beaucoup jours que
je réfléchis beaucoup à comment je
réfléchis notamment en maths mais pas
que et surtout matt et je trouve que
c'est une réflexion fascinant c'est pour
finir avec le psychologue reflet que je
suis eh bien je suis content que tu es
fais ton coming out
les normands mais sinon mais si moi
aussi je trouve ça fascinant de
comprendre comment réfléchit et comment
on comprend le monde mais voilà si tu me
donnes une unité de temps une minute je
vais j'ai l'impression que j'irais
plutôt la passe est allé apprendre des
contenus que parce que je suis là c'est
que je vais je trouve que j'ai
maintenant j'ai tout compris sur la
psychologie je n'ai plus rien à
apprendre
tu as les voiries géologue maintenant
voilà c'est ça je vais me reconvertir
bon bah merci beaucoup
stéphane c'était très sympa donc merci à
vous aussi d'avoir suivi à penser à
laquelle a commenté comme d'habitude et
à bientôt
probablement merci les études qui n'ont
pas laissé tourner la vidéo pendant 35
minutes là comme ça je m'en disent les
saintes il s enregistrer ses banques